GET ON THE RIGHT YEAH OKAY OKAY
WE HAVE --
WE HAVE SOME TIME COMMITMENTS ON
SOME OF THE MEMBERS SO WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS WE'RE GONNA
START OUR OUR HEARING OF THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
AND WE WILL REACH A QUORUM SOON
SO -- WE
WILL START THE MEETING AND THEN --
GO THROUGH THE PROCESS WE INVITE
ALL THE MEMBERS TO COME TO THE
CHAMBERS ALL THE MEMBERS IN THE
SENATE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
SO -- WE
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON.
THIS IS OUR FIRST HEARING --
TWENTY NINETEEN OF THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
AND TODAY --
WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT ROAD
REPAIR AND ACCOUNTABILITY ACT.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS SP.
ONE NOW IT'S FITTING THAT WE
START OUR NEW LEGISLATIVE
SESSION WITH SP ONE BECAUSE THE
KEY.
TO THE LONG TERM.
OF SUSTAINABILITY OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES MADE
STRONG EFFORTS TO DEMONSTRATE
RESULTS.
OF FROM SB ONE FUNDING LAST YEAR
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
OUR TRANSPORTATION FUNDING HAS
LAGGED.
FAR BEYOND THE NEED FOR FOR
DECADES AND WE HAVE A COURSE --
MAINTENANCE DEFICIT --
SO -- THE
WORK TO REPAIR TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM IS NOW JUST ONLY
BEGINNING.
TODAY WILL HEAR WHAT HAS BEEN
ACHIEVED WITH SP.
ONE OF SO FAR.
HAD CLOSE THE STATE AND LOCAL
LEVEL.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING
FROM OUR FIRST THE TWO PANELS
ABOUT OUR EFFORTS. TO BE
RESPONSIBLE WHERE THE APPROVAL
FROM THE VOTERS.
AND INCLUDED A OUR EFFORTS TO
MAKE.
OUR FUNDING SPENDING MORE
EFFICIENT IN DELIVERING OUR
TRANSPORTATION --
GRAMS.
OUR LAST EXPERTS WILL DISCUSS
THE FUTURE TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING.
AND THIS WILL BE THE RESULT OF
SOME OF THE RESEARCH --
DEBT WE STARTED WITH SP.
ONE OF WE HAVE OF FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH SP.
ONE ACTUALLY FUNDED SOME
TRANSPORTATION RESEARCH DONE BY.
A CONSORTIUM OF THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITIES AND WE'RE
GONNA HAVE OUR FIRST COUPLE
REPORTS.
OF RESEARCH DONE BY OUR RESEARCH
PEOPLE.
TODAY.
AND OR SESSION --
THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS --
I'D LIKE --
TO HAVE PARTS OF OUR MEETINGS.
WHEN WE'RE NOT OVER CROWDED WITH
BILLS AND SO FORTH? TO HAVE SOME
OF THE OTHER RESEARCHERS COME
AND TALK ABOUT THE OTHER STUFF
SUBJECTS THAT.
ARE BEING --
STUDIED.
IN TERMS OF TRANSPORTATION.
NOW --
FINALLY AFTER THAT WHAT ELSE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT IN.
I A AT THIS TIME WE'LL GET
STARTED WILL CALL THE PANELISTS
WHO BUT BEFORE.
WE START WE WANT TO KNOW IF
ANYBODY HAS ANY INITIAL
STATEMENTS FROM THE MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMITTEE.
ANYBODY HAVE A COMMENT YOU WANT
OF ME OKAY.
OKAY LET'S GO AHEAD AND REQUEST
TO OUR FIRST GROUP --
SP ONE ACCOMPLISHMENTS FROM THE
ST STE PERSPECTIVE AND WE HAVE.
SOME PANELISTS WILL HAVE --
HAVE THE PEOPLE COME FORWARD.
AND I BELIEVE --
MITCHELL WEISS IS THE CHIEF --
DEPUTY DIRECTOR HE WILL START IN
AND AROUND HERE RANDY ORTEGA'S
OUR INSPECTOR GENERAL.
CHAT ELLISON.
ZERO DEPUTY SECRETARY OF
TRANSPORTATION A STATE
CALIFORNIA AND MISTER JIM DAVIS
IS HRE -- I
KNOW HIM WELL HE USED TO BE MY
CALTRANS DISTRICT FOR DIRECTOR.
WELCOME JIM.
US SPECIAL ADVISER TO THE
DIRECTOR.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO --
I BELIEVE WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH THIS MITCHELL MITCHELL ARE
YOU FIRST I'M FIRST OKAY GO OKAY
MITCHELL HAS THE FLOOR WE'RE
GONNA TALK ABOUT THE STATE
GOVERNMENT AND WHAT THEY'RE
DOING WITH SB. ONE IN OTHER
PROGRAMS GOING INITIAL THANK YOU
FOR FOR FOR INVITING ME HERE TO
FIND AN UPDATE ON COMMISSIONS SP
ONE IMPLEMENTATION.
AS STATURE NOTED I AM A TWICE
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION.
THE COMMISSION RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROGRAMMING ALLOCATING A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
TRANSPORTATION FUNNY IN
CALIFORNIA.
IT'S ALSO CHARGED WITH ADVISING
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE SECRETARY
FOR TRANSPORTATION HAN
TRANSPORTATION POLICY ISSUES.
AS YOU KNOW THROUGH SB ONE THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING ESSENTIAL
FOR THE REPAIR OF CALIFORNIA'S
ROADS AND STATE HIGHWAYS. FOR
GOODS MOVEMENT TRANSIT INTERCITY
RAIL ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION AND
MULTI MODAL SOLUTIONS FOR
CONGESTED CORRIDORS.
THE FUNDING FROM SB ONE COMES
PRIMARILY FROM A TWELVE CENT
INCREASE IN THE GASOLINE EXCISE
TAX ALONG WITH INCREASES IN THE
TAX ON DIESEL FUELS.
AND NEW VEHICLE FEES.
SP ONE TO TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS SEVERAL OF THESE ARE
UNDER THE COMMISSION'S PURVIEW
OTHERS ARE OVERSEEN BY THE STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY IN
CALTRANS.
SB ONE ALSO ESTABLISHED KEY
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES TO
INCREASE AND IMPROVE OVERSIGHT
AND TRANSPARENCY.
IN THE FUNDING AND DELIVERY OF
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING THE
PASSAGE OF SB ONE COMMISSION
STAFF BEGAN WORKING TO DEVELOP
PROGRAMS THAT WOULD FUND FOR
CRITICAL TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS
WHILE ENSURING ACCOUNTABILITY
AND OVERSIGHT.
IN MAY TWENTY SEVENTEEN ONE
MONTH AFTER THE PASSAGE OF
SENATE BILL ONE THE COMMISSION
APPROVED IN SB ONE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN THAT LATE
OUT THE TIMELINE FOR DEVELOPING
PROGRAM GUIDELINES AND ADOPTING
PROGRAMS AND PROJECTS.
FOLLOWING THE ADOPTION OF THAT
PLAN THE COMMISSION BEGAN
DEVELOPING GUIDELINES FOR
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAMS BY HOLDING A
SERIES OF WORKSHOPS.
THROUGH WHICH RECEIVED A CONCERT
TO INPUT FROM ALL INTERESTED
STAKEHOLDERS OVER THE COURSE OF
ABOUT SIX MONTHS THE COMMISSION
HELD MORE THAN FORTY PUBLIC
WORKSHOPS.
AND BY DECEMBER TWENTY SEVENTEEN
HAD ADOPTED GUIDELINES AND ISSUE
CALLS FOR PROJECTS FOR THE SP
ONE PROGRAMS UNDER ITS PURVIEW.
THROUGHOUT TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
COMMISSION COMMITTED MORE THAN
NINE BILLION DOLLARS IN SB.
ONE FUNDING TO PROJECTS
BENEFITING PEOPLE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
THESE PROJECTS TOTAL TWENTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDING AND LEVERAGED
ANOTHER NINE BILLION DOLLARS IN
LOCAL FUNDS.
BY PLACING A HIGH PRIORITY ON
THE STATE OF GOOD REPAIR THE
COMMISSION FUNDED CRITICAL
REHABILITATION PRESERVATION AND
SAFETY PROJECTS. TO IMPROVE
ROADS BRIDGES TRANSIT SYSTEMS
AIRPORTS RAILROADS AND ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION FACILITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
THESE PROJECTS WILL BENEFIT
EVERY CITY IN COUNTY CALIFORNIA.
THEY WILL IMPROVE TRADE
CORRIDORS REDUCE CONGESTION IN
THE MOST HEAVILY USED QUARTERS
IN THE STATE PROVIDE SAFEROUTES
TO SCHOOLS.
IMPROVING EXPAND TRANSIT REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
COMMUNITY IMPACTS AND MORE.
THESE INVESTMENTS INCLUDE
EIGHTEEN BILLION DOLLARS IN FOUR
YEARS FOR THE STATE HIGHWAY
OPERATION PROTECTION PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM FUNDS CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS FOR THE MEAT AND
SAFETY OPERATION AND
REHABILITATION OF THE STATE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM.
AND IS ONE OF THE CORNERSTONES
OF SB ONE'S FOCUS ON FIX IT
FIRST INVESTMENTS.
SB ONE STABILIZE FUNDING FOR THE
STATE TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM.
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN STATE
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM INVESTED THREE POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS OVER FIVE YEARS.
THIS PROGRAM FUND STATE HIGHWAY
INTERCITY RAIL LOCAL ROAD AND
TRANSIT IMPROVEMENTS.
GUIDED BY COUNTY AND STATE
PRIORITIES.
THANKS TO SB ONE THE COMMISSION
WAS ABLE TO RESTORE FUNDING TO
SOME PROJECTS THAT WERE CUT FROM
THIS PROGRAM TWENTY SIXTEEN DUE
TO DECLINING REVENUE.
SB ONE CREATED THE TRADE
CORRIDOR ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM.
INITIAL ROUND OF INVESTMENTS FOR
THIS PROGRAM.
TOTALED ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS.
THIS PROGRAM FUNDS
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS ON
FEDERALLY DESIGNATED TRADE
CORRIDORS AND OTHER CORRIDORS
THAT HAVE A HIGH VOLUME OF
FREIGHT MOVEMENT. ONE PROJECT
FUNDED THROUGH THIS PROGRAM AT
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RAIL
PROJECT IN LOS ANGELES --
GOODS MOVEMENT AND SAFETY OR DO
THINK TRUCK TRIPS AND EMISSIONS
THROUGH THE USE OF ON DOC RAIL
AND GRADE SEPARATIONS.
SB ONE PROVIDED THREE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY SIX MILLION IN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND OVER ONE
BILLION IN. EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
FOR MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND TWO
THOUSAND LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS
PROGRAM PROJECTS.
THIS PROGRAM PROVIDES FUNDS TO
CITIES AND COUNTIES FOR BASIC
ROAD MAINTENANCE REHABILITATION
AND CRITICAL SAFETY PROJECTS ON
LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS.
AS ARE SORT OF THIS ANNUAL SB
ONE FUNDING SEVERAL CITIES WERE
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT THEIR FIRST
PAVEMENT MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS.
CULTURAL TRACT CAN BACKTRACK
PAVEMENT CONDITION DATA AND
ESTABLISHED A SYSTEM DECISION
MAKING PROCESS TO HELP CHOOSE
THE MOST EFFECTIVE ROAD
MAINTENANCE STRATEGIES.
THE COMMISSION'S SP ONE
INVESTMENTS INCLUDE A BILLION
DOLLARS FOR NINE PROJECTS IN THE
SOLUTIONS FOR CONGESTED
CORRIDORS PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM FUNDS PROJECTS TO
REDUCE CONGESTION AND HIGHLY
TRAVELED AND HIGHLY CONGESTED
CORRIDORS THROUGH PERFORMANCE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT BALANCE
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENTS.
COMMUNITY IMPACTS ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS. ONE OF THE PROJECTS
FUNDED IN THIS PROGRAM IS THAT
US FIFTY MULTI MODAL QUARTER
ENHANCEMENT PROJECT IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
THIS PROJECT WILL CONSTRUCT
FOURTEEN MILES OF HIGH OCCUPANCY
VEHICLE LANES ON US.
FIFTY AND ADD NEARLY NINE
THOUSAND FEET OF TREATABLE
TRACKING TO THE LIGHT RAIL
SYSTEM.
COMBINED THESE PROJECTS WILL
PROVIDE MORE TRANSPORTATION
ALTERNATIVES FOR COMMUTERS
DURING PEAK TRAVEL PERIODS.
INCLUDING CUTTING THE FOR SOME
FROM EVERY THIRTY MINUTES EVERY
FIFTEEN MINUTES.
SB ONE PROVIDED AN 80% INCREASE
IN FUNDING FOR THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM.
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF SB ONE THE
COMMISSION IS PROGRAM NEARLY
HALF A BILLION DOLLARS IN
PROJECTS. TO ENCOURAGE THE
INCREASED USE OF ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION MODES SUCH AS
BIKING AND WALKING WITH ANOTHER
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX MILLION
TO BE PROGRAMMED BY JUNE OF THIS
YEAR. ONE PROJECT FUNDED IN THIS
PROGRAM IS THE BETTER BIKE WAY
PROJECT ALONG SAN FERNANDO
STREET IN SAN JOSE.
THIS PROJECT WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
UPGRADE FUNCTIONALITY AND SAFETY.
BY CONSTRUCTING A CLASS FOR BIKE
FACILITY AND SHORTENING THE
CROSSING DISTANCE AT THIRTY
INTERSECTIONS.
THE COMMISSION'S SB ONE
INVESTMENTS INCLUDE SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM FIGHTS FUNNY TO
JURISDICTIONS IN WHICH VOTERS
HAVE APPROVED TAXES OR FEES
SOLELY DEDICATED TO
TRANSPORTATION OR WHICH HAVE
ENACTED FEES OR TAXES SOLELY
DEDICATED TO TRANSPORTATION.
BUT THE COMMISSION IMPLEMENTED
THE FIRST THREE YEARS OF THIS
PROGRAM HALF AS A COMPETITIVE
PROGRAM AND HALF AS FORMULAIC
PROGRAM. ONE OF THE PROJECTS
FUNDED IN THIS PROGRAM IS THE LA
METRO ORANGE LINE BUS RAPID
TRANSIT IMPROVEMENT PROJECT
WHICH WILL PROVIDE IMPROVEMENTS
ALONG THE METRO ORANGE LINE
ROUTE INCLUDING AN AERIAL.
GRADE SEPARATED STRUCTURE OVER
FIVE INTERSECTIONS AND EATING
SYSTEM AT THIRTY FOUR
INTERSECTIONS.
IN ADDITION TO PROVIDING MUCH
NEEDING FUNDING SP ONE INCLUDED
MEASURES INTENDED TO HOLD
RECIPIENTS OF SB ONE FUNDS
ACCOUNTABLE.
AS SPECIFICALLY SB ONE REALLY
STATED THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF TRANSPORTATION AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
FOR THE EFFICIENT INVESTMENT
PUBLIC FUNDS TO MAINTAIN PUBLIC
HIGHWAYS STREETS AND ROADS.
AND ARE ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
PEOPLE THROUGH PERFORMANCE GOALS
THAT ARE TRACKED AND REPORTED.
IN MARCH TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
COMMISSION ADOPTED ITS SB ONE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
GUIDELINES WHICH SET FORTH THE
COMMISSION'S ACCOUNTABILITY
REQUIREMENTS.
TOLD CALTRANS A LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
EFFICIENT INVESTMENT A PUBLIC
FUNDS.
THROUGH PROGRAM MONITORING AND
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
AS A KEY PART OF THESE
GUIDELINES THE COMMISSION
REQUIRES BASELINE AGREEMENTS FOR
SPECIFIED PROGRAMS AND PROJECTS.
THESE AGREEMENTS ESTABLISH THE
PROJECT SCOPE EXPECTED
PERFORMANCE BENEFITS DELIVERY
SCHEDULE BUDGET AND FUNDING PLAN.
SB ONE INCLUDED SEVERAL TENURE
PERFORMANCE TARGETS FOR THE
STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM.
REQUIRING NOT LESS THAN 90% 90%
OF THE PAYMENT ON THE STATE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM BEING GOOD OR
FAIR CONDITION.
NOT LESS THAN 90% LEVEL OF
SERVICE BE ACHIEVED FOR THE
MAINTENANCE OF POTHOLES BALLS
AND CRACKS.
NOT LESS THAN 90% OF CULVERTS
BEING GOOD OR FAIR CONDITION NOT
LESS THAN 90% OF TRANSPORTATION
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM UNITS BEING
GOOD CONDITION.
AND FIXING NOT LESS THAN AN
ADDITIONAL. FIVE TO MEASURE
PROGRESS TOWARDS MEETING THE
DEFINED PERFORMANCE TARGETS THE
COMMISSION REQUIRED CALTRANS. TO
DEVELOP ANNUAL BENCHMARKS TO
MEASURE PROGRESS MADE.
BASED ON INFORMATION AND
ANALYSIS PRESENTED BY CALTRANS.
THE COMMISSION FOUND THAT
INTERMEDIATE ANNUAL PANTS WITH
BENCHMARKS ARE BEING MET AND
THAT PROGRESS IS BEING MADE JUST
TOWARDS ACHIEVING THE TENURE
SYSTEM PERFORMANCE TARGETS.
ESTABLISHED BY SB.
ONE THE COMMISSION HAS BEGUN
LOOKING AHEAD TOWARD NEXT ROUND
OF SB ONE PROGRAMMING.
WE HAVE REFLECTED ON OUR WORK
OVER THE PAST YEAR TO HELP
INFORM OUR WORK MOVING FORWARD.
STARTING NEXT MONTH WILL BE
HOLDING PUBLIC WORKSHOPS FOR
<c.cyan>0C UPCOMING PROGRAMMING</c>
CYCLES.
ON MARCH TWELFTH AND TWENTY
FIRST WILL BE HOLDING WORKSHOPS
IN LOS ANGELES AND SACRAMENTO
RESPECTIVELY. FOR THE TREE COURT
OR ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM.
THE SOLUTIONS FOR IN JUST
QUARTERS PROGRAM AND LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM.
THESE WORKSHOPS WILL PROVIDE A
FORUM FOR US TO COLLABORATE WITH
PARTNER AGENCIES STAKEHOLDERS IN
THE PUBLIC.
AND TO FURTHER STRENGTHEN OUR
GUIDELINES AND IMPROVE OUR
REPORTING PROCESSES.
THAT CONCLUDES MY TESTIMONY BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY WE'LL HOLD QUESTIONS THE TO
TELL ALL THE OTHER PANELISTS --
HAVE FINISHED OKAY AROUND HERE
OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR SO A GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY MY NAME'S
THE RAIN OR TAKE --
INSPECTOR GENERAL CALTRANS.
THE SERGEANTS PASSING OUT A
HANDOUT THAT I PLAN TO SPEAK
FROM THIS AFTERNOON --
THANK YOU IT WILL BE HELPFUL --
THE FIRST PAGE OF THE HANDOUT IS
OUR WHERE I THOUGHT IT WOULD
START WHICH IS THE ORGANIZATION
OF THE OFFICE --
SO FAR SO.
AS YOU ALL KNOW THE THE
INDEPENDENT OFFICE OF AUDITS
INVESTIGATIONS WAS ESTABLISHED
IN SB ONE IT HAS A BROAD CHARGE
TO ENSURE THE EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE USE OF RESOURCES BY
CALTRANS AND BY LOCAL ENTITIES
WHO RECEIVE FUNDING FROM
CALTRANS --
YOU MAY NOT KNOW THAT A LEADER --
BUDGET --
BILL IN A BUDGET PROPOSAL
COMBINED THE EXISTING INTERNAL
AUDIT FUNCTION THAT CALTRANS HAD
AND THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
OFFICE.
AND SO A GOOD PART OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN INVOLVED --
DOING A LITTLE BIT OF WORK TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO INCORPORATE
THE TWO MISSIONS WHAT THE
INTERNAL WORK THAT WAS ALREADY
ON GOING AND THEN THIS --
OF NEW CHARGE TO AN INSPECTOR
GENERAL THAT WAS INDEPENDENT OF
THE DEPARTMENT AND REPORTING --
TO EXTERNAL ENTITIES REPORTING
TO THE CDC LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR AND SO --
WHAT YOU HAVE HERE IS HOW SO FAR?
AN ADDITIONAL --
CHANGE THAT CAME AFTER SB ONE
PASSED WAS THE PASSAGE OF SB ONE
OF THREE WHICH WAS --
IN PART --
EIGHTY TRICK A BUDGET TRAILER
BILL KIND OF CLEAN UP BILL --
MAKING SOME CHANGES THAT --
CAME UP IN SB ONE AND THEN ALSO --
ADDING SOME NEW ITEMS ONE OF
THOSE NEW ITEMS WAS A CHARGE TO
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL TO REPORT
ON A CALTRANS IS EFFORTS TO
INCREASE CONTRACTS WITH
DISADVANTAGED BUSINESSES AND
SMALL BUSINESSES.
AND SO AS A RESULT OF THAT BILL
THE GOVERNOR APPOINTED A DEPUTY
INSPECTOR GENERAL FOR DIVERSITY
AND SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
AND SO YOU SEE THAT BOX --
ON THE ON THE ORGANIZATIONAL
CHART AND DEBBIE LUMPKIN IS
CHARGED WITH --
LOOKING OUT THE OUTREACH EFFORTS
AND THE SMALL BUSINESS --
AND DISADVANTAGED BUSINESS
OUTREACH.
JUST GETTING INTO A LITTLE BIT
OF THE THE DIFFERENT OFFICES
WITHIN.
THE AUDIT FUNCTION.
THE WAY WE IT IS AROUND THE
MAJOR PROGRAMS THAT CAL TRANS SO
UNDER EACH OF THESE HEADINGS
FINANCE AND OPERATIONS PROJECT
DELIVERY PLANNING IN MODAL
YOU'LL SEE THE MAJOR PROGRAM
AREAS THAT CALTRANS AND SO
THAT'S HOW WE'VE --
TRY TO ORGANIZE THE OFFICE AT
THIS POINT AND THEN FINALLY
THERE'S A CATEGORY OF ALL
INVESTIGATIONS AND THAT IS THE
STAFF THAT DOES THE
INVESTIGATIONS INTO
ADMINISTRATIVE MISCONDUCT.
MOVING ON TO PAGE THREE THIS IS
A AN EXCERPT FROM THE FIRST
REPORT THAT WE SUBMITTED TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN NOVEMBER --
IT REPORTS TO YOU AND AND TO THE
PUBLIC BECAUSE IT IS POSTED ON
OUR WEBSITE.
OF THE NUMBER OF AUDITS THAT
WERE COMPLETED IN DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES --
WOULD MAKE ONE NOTE FOR YOU ON
UNDER THE HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX
ON ITS THAT'S CALTRANS PROGRAMS
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS LOCAL
AGENCY AUDITS AND THEN.
A LARGE CATEGORY IS PROPOSITION
ONE BE ON ITS AND YOU MAY RECALL
THAT THOSE AUDITS ARE REQUIRED
BY THE BOND MEASURE --
BUT THAT OF COURSE WILL BE
DECLINING OVER TIME AND AS WITH
THE RESOURCES.
DEDICATED TO THOSE AUDITS --
A COUPLE OTHER CATEGORIES I
WOULD KNOW FOR YOU THE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY ONE FINANCIAL DOCUMENT
REVIEWS THESE ARE ESSENTIALLY
BIDS THAT COME INTO CALTRANS
THAT -- OUR
STAFF WORKS ON REVIEWING THOSE
ON IN MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS
BACK TO CALTRANS ABOUT --
WHAT SHOULD BE IN --
INCLUDED OR NOT INCLUDED IN A IN
A CONTRACT MOVING HEARING FIRMS --
AS I MENTIONED THERE'S AN
INVESTIGATIONS UNIT OF THAT UNIT
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR BOTH OF THEM
COMPLAINTS THAT COME IN.
REGARDING EMPLOYEE MISCONDUCT
BUT ALSO A WE ARE NOW OPERATING
THE CALTRANS ETHICS HELPLINE IT
SO QUAN SORRY WHISTLEBLOWER
HOTLINE IT DOESN'T QUITE HAVE
THE STATUTORY.
PROTECTIONS OR STRUCTURE AS SAY
THE STATE AUDITOR'S
WHISTLEBLOWER HOTLINE BUT IT IT
DOES REALLY FUNCTION THAT WAY IN
THAT EMPLOYEES CAN CALL IN AND
REPORT ANY CONCERNS THEY HAVE
ABOUT --
WASTE FRAUD ABUSE OR ETHICAL
LAPSES.
OUT OF THE NINETY ONE COMPLAINTS
OF MISCONDUCT IN THE OF THE
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN YEAR TWENTY
EIGHT WERE SUBSTANTIATED.
A MOVING DOWN TO THE OTHER
CATEGORY THAT I WOULD KNOW THE
SEVENTY FIVE LOCAL AGENCY
REVIEWS THESE ARE OF REVIEWS ARE
FOLKS DO OF RATES THAT ARE
CHARGED BY LOCAL ENTITIES THE
CALTRANS SO WE DO A REVIEW OF
WHETHER.
A LOCAL AGENCIES --
OVERHEAD RATE THAT THEY CHARGE
CALTRANS IS APPROPRIATE AND
THAT'S WHERE THOSE REVIEWS COME
IN.
MOVING TO PAGE FOUR OF THE JUST
QUICKLY THIS IS.
OF THE SAME INFORMATION THAT YOU
SAW ON PAGE THREE BUT THIS IS
FOR QUARTER ONE QUARTER TO OF
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN OF MOST MOST
OF IT LOOKS TO BE ON TRACK WITH
THE PRIOR FISCAL YEAR I WOULD
NOTE THOUGH THAT --
IF YOU LOOK AT THE CALL OF OUR
THE THE CATEGORY THE FINANCIAL
DOCUMENT REVIEWS OF
ARCHITECTURAL ENGINEERING FIRMS
YOU'LL SEE THAT WERE ALREADY AT
A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOR TWO
QUARTERS.
WHEREAS LAST YEAR WAS A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY ONE TO INCREASES ONE
IS.
A AN INCREASE IN IN THE THE
NUMBER OF BEDS THAT ARE COMING
AND SO THE ADS CALTRANS IS
RAMPING UP THE NUMBER PROJECTS
THAT ARE GOING OUT --
WE'RE DOING MORE REVIEWS TO TO
GET THOSE PROJECTS GOING SO I
THINK IT REFLECTS THE INCREASED
WORKLOAD AS A RESULT OF SB.
ONE AND THEN ALSO INCREASES THE
REFLECTS AN INCREASE THAT AS A
RESULT OF A BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT
WAS APPROVED LAST YEAR THAT
ALLOWED US TO EXPAND SOME
LOOKING INTO THE BITS AGO INTO
LOCAL AGENCIES SO WHAT WE'RE
DOING BOTH THE STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCY CONTRACTOR HE'S.
MOVING THE PAGE --
FIVE AND SIX JUST HERE I THOUGHT
I WOULD HIGHLIGHT TO AUDITS THAT
WERE RELEASED IN --
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT ARE
SPECIFIC TO SB ONE SO ONE IS --
THE WHAT WE CALL THE BASELINE
FOR SB ONE PERFORMANCE OUTCOMES --
THIS IS AN AUDIT THAT THE STAFF
DID -- TO
REALLY INSURE THAT THERE WAS AN
ACCURATE BASELINE FOR MEASURING
SOME OF THESE THINGS GOING
FORWARD SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
MEASURING THE NUMBER BRIDGES
FIXED OR THE NUMBER OF OF
COLBERT'S REPAIRED AND
IDENTIFIED.
IS WE DID THE DEPARTMENT
ESTABLISH AN APPROPRIATE
BASELINE SO THAT IN FIVE YEARS
IF YOU'RE MEASURING THE OUTCOMES
CAN WE BE SURE THAT WE'RE
COMPARING APPLES TO APPLES AND
WE REALLY DID GET --
THOSE DOLLARS --
ONE CATEGORY THAT WAS NOT
COMPLETED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
IS UNDER WAY NOW IS A REVIEW OF
THE BASS LINE ON PAVEMENT AND SO --
ESTABLISHING THE APPROPRIATE
MEASUREMENT OF THE PAVEMENT
CONDITION TO COMPARE THAT TO THE
OUTCOMES OVER TIME.
PAGE SIX TALKS ABOUT AN AUDIT WE
DID ON THE EFFICIENCY MEASURES
SO AS YOU ALL KNOW SB ONE
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT TO
IDENTIFY. ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS AND EFFICIENCIES --
FOR THOSE FUNDS TO BE REINVESTED
INTO A REHABILITATION AND
MAINTENANCE --
THIS AUDIT FOCUSED PRIMARILY ON
THE METHODOLOGY THAT THE
DEPARTMENT USED IN IS IN
IDENTIFYING AND REPORTING THE
EFFICIENCY MEASURES.
TO THE CITY SEE A WE DID NOT IN
THIS AUDIT GET INTO WHETHER THE
DOLLARS THAT THEY CALCULATED
WERE ACCURATE THAT IS THE AUDIT
THAT IS UNDER WAY TODAY SO WE
REALLY FOCUS ON METHODOLOGY --
LOOKING AT DID THEY ESTABLISH A
PROPER A PROPER BASELINE PUT IN
TRACKING MEASURES AND DO THEY
HAVE THE SUPORT TO DOCUMENT THE
SAVINGS ARE ACTUALLY THERE --
WE ALSO --
AS A RESULT OF THAT PROCESS
CREATED A CAN OF ONE PAGE
GUIDANCE DOCUMENT THAT WE HAVE
SHARED WITH THE OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S PROGRAMS. TO HELP
THEM THINK ABOUT AS THEY'RE
LOOKING AT CHANGES THAT THEY'RE
MAKING HOW WOULD THEY HOW WOULD
THEY USE AN APPROPRIATE
METHODOLOGY SAVINGS AND THEN
REPORTED ON FUTURE EFFICIENCY --
MEASURE REPORTS.
SO MOVING TO PAGE SEVEN THIS IS
A JUST A LIST OF SOME UPCOMING
AUDIT REPORTS THAT I THOUGHT YOU
MIGHT BE INTERESTED IN THESE
WILL BE COMING OUT WITHIN THE
NEXT.
FEW MONTHS OF MOST OF THEM ARE
TIED SPECIFICALLY TO SB ONE
DIRECTION'S OR SB ONE OF THREE
SO AS I MENTIONED THERE'S THE IN
EFFICIENCY MEASURES VERIFICATION
AUDIT THIS IS WHERE WE WILL
ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT A DO WE SEE
THIS THE SAVINGS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IDENTIFIED --
RELATED TO SB ONE OH THREE
THERE'S A AN AUDIT ON GOING
AROUND THE CERTIFICATION OF
DISADVANTAGED BUSINESSES AND
INSURING AS SB ONE OF THREE
REQUIRED THAT A BUSINESSES ARE
NOT ATTEMPTING TO CIRCUMVENT
THOSE RULES --
SB ONE ASKED THAT WE REVIEW THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF CALTRANS IS --
ENTERPRISE RISK MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM THAT ALL GETS UNDERWAY
AGAIN I MENTIONED THE PICK THE
PAVEMENT BASS LINE AUDIT --
WE HAVE A REVIEW OF THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM BOTH THE
INTERNAL OPERATION OF THAT
PROGRAM AND THE MANAGEMENT OF
THOSE DOLLARS AND ALSO SOME
LOCAL ENTITIES WHO RECEIVED.
ATP GRANTS --
THERE'S A AUDIT OF THE DIVISION
OF REAL A MASS TRANSIT.
THAT WILL BE COMING OUT SHORTLY
AN EIGHTY REVIEW OF THE
DISPARITY STUDY --
WHICH IS THE STUDY THAT ACTUALLY
LEADS -- TO
THE DISADVANTAGED BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE GOALS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HOUSE TO A CHIEF.
SO I'M GONNA STOP MY REMARKS
THERE AND I'LL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE END.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
CHARTER EDISON THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY OF TRANSPORTATION JOHN
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN DEL IN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
CHAD ADDISON W. SECULAR
TRANSPORTATION AT THE STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY THANK YOU
FOR INVITING ME TODAY.
I'M HERE TODAY TO REPORT ON THE
PROGRESS WE'RE MAKING AROUND THE
STATE ON TRANSIT AND INTERCITY
RAIL PROJECTS AND SERVICE THANKS
IN LARGE PART TO THE SENATE BILL --
ONE FUNDING DEDICATED TO THESE
PURPOSES BY THE LEGISLATURE.
CALTRANS WILL DISCUSS OTHER
IMPORTANT ASPECTS OF SB ONE
IMPLEMENTATION ONE TIME COMPLETE.
HI GIVEN THE MY SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTISE ISRAEL IN TRANSIT I
WILL DISCUSS THE FIVE POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS OF
TRANSLATING INTERCITY RAIL.
A CAPITAL PROGRAM FUNDING
PROGRAMS TO DATE.
AS WELL AS THE PROGRESS MADE IN
DISTRIBUTING OVER A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OF STATE RAIL
ASSISTANCE TO COMMUTER AN
INTERCITY RAIL AGENCIES IN THE
FUTURE OF BOTH PROGRAMS.
SENSE THE AT TWENTY FOURTEEN
CREATION OF THE TRANSIT
INTERCITY RAIL CAPITAL PROGRAM
OVER FIVE BILLION DOLLARS HAS
BEEN PROGRAMMED TO FIFTY SIX
PROJECTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND GIVEN THAT OUR STATE FUNDING
ONLY MAKES UP A PORTION OF THE
FUNDING USE ON THESE PROJECTS
WHEN YOU COMBINE OTHER STATE
FEDERAL AND LOCAL FUNDS.
AND THE TOTAL INVESTMENT IN
THESE PROJECTS EXCEEDS TWENTY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS.
I'M THOUSANDS OF JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA TIED TO THESE
PROJECTS IN ALMOST ALL OF THE
PROJECTS ARE PROVIDING NEEDED
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENTS TO
DISADVANTAGED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES.
OVER EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OF OUR FUNDING HAS BEEN
ALLOCATED TO DATE.
AND A GREAT DEAL MORE IS
EXPECTED TO BE REQUESTED FOR
ALLOCATION IN THE COMING FISCAL
YEAR.
WE HAVE SUPPORTED TRANSFORMATIVE
PROJECTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
JOSE --
AREN'T WE WE'VE CONTRIBUTED
SIGNIFICANT TIME TO GET THAT THE
GROWTH OF BARK CAPACITY UNDER
UNDER THE DAY ON THE EXISTING
SYSTEM.
ADDING THIRTY SEVEN RAIL CARS TO
THE CALTRAIN ORDERS THAT CAN
OPERATE SEVEN CAR TRAINS ON ALL
TEAM INTO SAN FRANCISCO SERVICES
AFTER COMPLETING ELECTRIFICATION.
INVESTING IN MAJOR TRANSIT
SERVICE EXPANSIONS BY LA METRO.
LA D. O. T.'S DASH SYSTEMIC
METROLINK IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
HELPING ENABLE THE FULL
ELECTRIFICATION OF THE ANTELOPE
VALLEY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY'S BUS FLEET.
EXTEND IN CINEMA MARIN AREA RAIL
TRANSIT TO WINDSOR IN LARKSPUR --
REQUIRING EXPANSION LIGHT RAIL
FLEET FOR SAN FRANCISCO MUNY IN
SACRAMENTO REGIONAL TRANSIT.
SUPPORTING THE ORANGE COUNTY
STREETCAR.
GROWING ALAMEDA QUARTER
EXPRESSED AN INTEREST IN JOAQUIN
SERVICE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND WITH ADDITIONAL FREQUENCIES
TO SACRAMENTO ON BOTH SYSTEMS.
AND SIGNIFICANT OTHER TRANSIT
AND RAIL IMPROVEMENTS IN SAN
DIEGO THE INLAND EMPIRE ON THE
CENTRAL COAST IN ALL THE WAY
INTO THE NORTH STATE WITH
ELECTRIC BUS SERVICE BETWEEN
SACRAMENTO AND READING.
SB ONE FUNDING HAS SIGNIFICANTLY
HELPED ENABLE THESE WIDE RANGING
COMMITMENTS.
THE PROGRAM IS SCHEDULED TO MAKE
ON GOING INVESTMENTS WITH
ADDITIONAL PROGRAMMING EVERY TWO
YEARS.
THE NEXT CALL FOR PROJECTS WILL
GO OUT IN APPROXIMATELY MID
SEPTEMBER WITH THE WORDS BEING
MADE BY APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY
AND EVERY TWO YEARS THEREAFTER.
SB ONE ALSO CREATED ANOTHER
PROGRAM THAT THE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY ADMINISTERS.
THE STATE RAIL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM FUNDED WITH HALF A
PERCENT OF THE DIESEL SALES AND
USE TAX.
EXPECTED TO GENERATE A
CUMULATIVE REVENUE OF JUST OVER
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS BY THE
END OF NEXT FISCAL YEAR.
IN OVER FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
PER YEAR THERE AFTER THIS
PROGRAM DELIVER SEVEN EIGHTHS OF
ITS REVENUE. TO COMMUTER AND
INTERCITY RAIL SERVICES ON A
FORMULA BASIS.
WITH A SMALL AMOUNT OF INTERCITY
RAIL FUNDING FOR DISCRETIONARY
ALLOCATION TO EMERGING IN
EXPANDING RAIL SERVICES.
THE REVENUE FOR THIS PROGRAM IS
HELPING SUPPORT BOTH CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS AND OPERATIONS BY A
REAL PROVIDERS.
THIS NOVEMBER AND RAIL TRANSIT
SYSTEM IS USING ITS FUNDING TO
OFFER INCREASED WEEKDAY AND
WEEKEND RAIL OPERATIONS.
MR IN SAN DIEGO IS USING ITS
FUNDS TO HELP PURCHASE FIVE
CLEAN TEAR FOR SIEMENS CHARGER
LOCOMOTIVES BUILT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
ALAMEDA QUARTER EXPRESSIBLE USE
ITS FUNDS TO RUN THROUGH
SATURDAY SERVICES.
IN OUR OTHER OPERATORS ARE USING
FUNDS TO PURSUE MANY VALUABLE
SMALL AND LARGE CAPITAL PROJECTS.
MOST OF THE FUNDING HAS ALREADY
BEEN PROGRAM THROUGH NEXT FISCAL
YEAR ABOUT THIRTEEN MILLION OF
DISCRETIONARY MONEY WILL BE
AWARDED TO INNER CITY RAIL
AGENCIES IN THE VERY NEAR FUTURE --
AND THEN LOOKING FORWARD WE
EXPECT ADDITIONAL PROJECTS TO
COMMIT BE COMMITTED TO STARTING
WITH THE FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THIS REVENUE STREAM ALONG WITH
THE INCREASE TO TRANSIT FORMULA
ASSISTANCE A THE FLOWS THROUGH
OTHER SB ONE PROGRAM'S IS
INVALUABLE TO GROWING IN
IMPROVING OUR TRANSIT SERVICES
STATEWIDE.
THE NEW REVENUES OF SUPPORTED
INCREDIBLY VALUABLE PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND WE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH FUTURE
PROJECTS SPONSORS TO HELP THEM
DEVELOP GOOD PROJECTS THAT FIT
WELL WITH THE PROGRAM OBJECTIVES.
SO WE CAN GROW TRANSIT AND RAIL
RIDERSHIP WHILE REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME GLAD
TO TAKE QUESTIONS AT THE END.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
W. SECRETARY AS JIM DAVIS FROM
CALTRANS.
YOU HAVE THE FOR GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR SENATORS MY NAME IS
JIM DAVIS IN MY CURRENT ROLE
CALTRANS IS SPECIAL ADVISER TO
DIRECTOR BERMAN.
I'M GLAD TO BE HERE TODAY TO
TALK ABOUT THE GREAT THINGS
CALTRANS IS DOING WITH SB WANT.
SB ONE PROVIDE AN ESTIMATED
FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS OVER
THE NEXT TEN YEARS HAVE FOR THE
STATE.
AND NOW FOR THE LOCALS.
I'M GLAD REPORT THE CALTRANS IS
ON TARGET TO MEET THE
PERFORMANCE GOALS.
THE CHIEF DEPUTY WISE TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER.
WHILE ALSO MEANER EFFICIENCY
GOALS OF A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF THIS
LEGISLATION CALTRANS IS
COMPLETED NINETY PROJECTS IN
OVER FOUR HUNDRED MORE WILL
PROJECTS ARE IN THE WORKS.
THIS INCLUDES REHABILITATED MORE
THAN THIRTEEN HUNDRED LANE MILES
OF PAVEMENT.
FIXING THE SEVENTY ONE BRIDGES.
AND INCREASING VISIBILITY FOR
DRIVERS WITH HIGHLY REFLECTIVE
SIX INCH LANE STRIPING OF MORE
THAN SEVEN THOUSAND LANE MILES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
IN THE COMING HERE CAL TRANS
WILL FIX AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED LANE MILES OF
PAVEMENT.
MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
BRIDGES. FIVE THOUSAND DRAINAGE
SYSTEMS ALMOST TEN THOUSAND
MILES A NEW LANE STRIPING.
AND MORE THAN TWELVE HUNDRED
CONGESTION REDUCING TRAFFIC
MANAGEMENT ELEMENTS.
THESE NUMBERS ARE IMPRESSIVE BUT
EVEN THEY DO NOT FULLY TELL THE
STORY WOULD A GAME CHANGER SB
ONE COMBINED WITH CALTRANS NEW
ASSET MANAGER PLAN.
IS PROVING TO BE.
CALTRANS IS WORKING BETTER.
FASTER AND SMARTER.
WITH PROJECT PROGRAMMING NOW
BEEN DRIVEN AT THE DISTRICT
LEVEL FORCES AT THE STATE LEVEL
AND STARTING ADDRESS MULTIPLE
ASSET CLASSES.
IN A SINGLE PROJECT.
THIS DEMONSTRATES THE SHIFT FROM
SILO BASED APPROACH. TO SYSTEM
WIDE ASSESSMENT.
PERFORMANCE DRIVER APPROACH TO
INVESTMENT.
WE'VE GIVEN DISTRICTS
PERFORMANCE MEASURES. TO ME
PAIRED WITH THE MONEY. TO MEET
THEM.
THIS IS THE HOUSE DISTRICTS MORE
FLEXIBILITY ACCOUNTABILITY IN
OPPORTUNITY FIND CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS.
IT HAS BETTER PARTNERS WITH
LOCAL AGENCIES HAS DISTRICTS
FIND MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
JOINT PROJECTS MAKING BOTH.
STATE AND LOCAL DOLLARS MORE
EFFECTIVE.
WE'VE ALSO PRODUCED A TEN YOUR
BOOK. TEN YEARS WORTH OF
PROJECTS. TO HELP US LOOK INTO
THE FUTURE AT THE PROJECT THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE WORKING ON IN A
START BE ABLE TO PARTNER WITH
OUR LOCAL PARTNERS TO LOOK IN
THE FUTURE WHAT PART IS WE CAN
PARTNER.
CAN BECOME MORE EFFICIENT
TOGETHER.
LET ME HIGHLIGHT A FEW EXAMPLES
OF SB ONE PROJECTS. ONE POINT
TWO BILLION WE SPENT ON PROJECTS
ON INTERSTATE TEN IN SAN
BERNARDINO AND RIVERSIDE
COUNTIES WHICH WILL INCLUDE
BRIDGE REPLACEMENT.
PAVEMENT REPLACEMENT
IMPROVEMENTS TO OLDER'S AND
RAMPS.
IMPROVING THIS VITAL ECONOMIC
QUARTER IS IMPERATIVE BUSINESSES
AND INDIVIDUALS ALIKE.
THE FIVE HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
DOLLAR GOLDEN STATE CHOKE POINT
RELIEF PROJECT ON INTERSTATE
FIVE BETWEEN BECAUSE STAKE IN
SANTA CLARITA.
RECEIVED TWO HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN
MILLION IN SB ONE TRADE QUARTER
FUNDS.
IN TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION AND
LOCAL FUNDS TO LEVERAGE FORTY
SEVEN MILLION IN FEDERAL AND FOR
GRANT FUNDED.
THE PROJECT WILL ADD TRUCK LANES
IN CARPOOL LANES.
IMPROVING TRAFFIC SAFETY
CONGESTION AND FREE MOBILITY.
HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION
WILL BE SPENT ON PROJECTS ON THE
VITAL INTERSTATE EIGHT EIGHTY
FREIGHT AND COMMUTE CORRIDOR IN
THE BAY AREA. TO VAMP BRIDGES
MAKE COMPLETE STREET
IMPROVEMENTS SMOOT TRAFFIC FLOW
WITH RENT METERS REPLACE OTHER
TRAFFIC MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
ELEMENTS.
REPLACING A REHABILITATION TWO
HUNDRED LANE MILES OF PAVEMENT.
AND HAD A CONCRETE MEDIAN
BARRIER ON A SEGMENT IN OAKLAND.
ALMOST THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY NEW
NINE MILLION WILL BE SPENT.
ON SIXTEEN PROJECTS ON HIGHWAY
NINETY NINE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
IMPROVING PAVEMENT.
BRIDGES AND DRAINAGE ON IS VITAL
ROUTE.
MORE EXAMPLES OF STATE AND LOCAL
SB ONE PROJECTS WILL CONTINUE BE
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC UNDER
WEBSITE REBUILDING CA DOT CA DOT
G. O. V..
AS PART OF CALTRANS COMMITMENT
TO TRANSPARENCY.
ANOTHER IMPORTANT COMPONENT OR
THE INNOVATIONS CALTRANS IS
PURSUING TO MEET THE EFFICIENCY
REQUIREMENT OF SB.
ONE CALTRANS IS FOCUSED ON
IDENTIFYING DEFICIENCIES IN
THREE AREAS.
PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS.
TECHNOLOGY AND INNOVATIVE TOOLS
AND SAVED A HUNDRED THIRTY THREE
MILLION LAST YEAR.
A SIGNIFICANT PROCESS CHANGE
CAME IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN WHEN
CALTRANS BEGAN STREAMLINING MORE
THAN THIRTEEN THOUSAND FEDERAL
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEWS WERE TAKEN
ON THE ASSIGNMENT OF THE FEDERAL
HIGHWAY ADMINISTRATION
RESPONSIBILITIES.
UNDER THE NATIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION ACT.
THIS IS SERVED AN AVERAGE OF
APPROXIMATELY SAVED
APPROXIMATELY --
AVERAGE OF ONE YEAR FOR COMPLEX
IN FORMAL DOCUMENTS.
EXAMPLES IN THE PAST AND COULD
BE ANY ARC BRIDGE THE DUMBARTON
BRIDGE IMPROVEMENTS AND CARPOOL
LANES AND REPAVING INTERSTATE
FIVE IN STOCKTON.
AND ADD A RECONSTRUCTED
INTERCHANGE AND WHINING IN THE
MOB THE BRIDGE ON INTERSTATE.
FIFTEEN STATUTORY AUTHORITY FOR
THIS PROGRAM IS SET TO EXPIRE AT
THE END OF THIS YEAR.
EVEN THOUGH WE'RE LOOKING AT
WAYS TO STREAMLINE OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL ASSIGNMENT FROM
THE ANOTHER KEY PROCESS
IMPROVEMENT HAS BEEN THE USE OF
VALUE ANALYSIS WHICH IS REVIEW
PROCESS DESIGNED ELIMINATE
UNNECESSARY COSTS. TO DO NOT ADD
QUALITY GRANT ELEMENTS THAT ADD
VALUE TO PROJECT.
CALTRANS ABORTED SIXTY TWO
MILLION COSTS USING THIS PROCESS
LAST YEAR.
SINCE THEN HAS SINCE THE SUCCESS
OF WHAT WE SEE IN THE VA PROGRAM
WE HAVE LOWERED THE PROJECT
DOLLARS THRESHOLD FOR ENGAGING
IN THIS REVIEW FROM FIFTY
MILLION WHICH GENERATE THOSE
DOLLARS TO NOW TWENTY FIVE
MILLION. TWO CHIEF EVEN MORE
SAVINGS.
ANOTHER PROCESS CHANGE WE HAVE
BEEN INSTIGATED IS THAT OF
BUNDLING PROJECTS.
BY GROUPING DIFFERENT ASSET
PROJECTS IN THE SAME LOCATION WE
CAN BENEFIT FROM ECONOMIES OF
SCALE.
WE ALSO CREATE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PARTNERING
WITH OUR LOCAL AGENCIES.
AND WE ARE STOPPING A PROJECT
RELATED PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS.
LAST YEAR WE PUT A MASS HIRING
EVENTS ON BROUGH NEEDED STAFF
MORE QUICKLY AND EFFICIENTLY
THIS ALLOWED US TO HIRE SIX
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX EMPLOYEES TO
DELIVER PROJECTS.
MORE QUICKLY.
CALTRANS ISN'T PILOTING AN
INNOVATIVE CONTRACTING TO CALL
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER GENERAL
CONTRACTOR OR CMG CITY.
THIS CONTRACTING TOOL ALLOWS
CALTRANS TO HIRE A CONTRACTOR
DURING THE DESIGN PROCESS.
PROVIDING A VALUABLE INPUT THAT
CAN REDUCE COSTS AND CHANGE
ORDER.
IN BETTER MANAGE RHYS.
CALTRANS SAVE MORE THAN EIGHTY
MILLION A FIVE PROJECTS LAST
YEAR INCLUDING MORE THAN FORTY
FOUR MILLION ON SB ONE FUNDED
PROJECTS.
LAST YEAR WITH THE HELP OF
CENTER BELL.
THE LEGISLATURE RECOGNIZED THE
POTENTIAL OF THIS TOOL PROVIDED
CALTRANS WITH PERMANENT CMG SEE
IF THE WORD.
WE'RE INCREASING THE USE OF THIS
TOOL IN THE COMING YEARS TO
PRODUCE EVEN MORE SAVINGS.
ON THE TECHNOLOGY FRONT CALTRANS
IS DEVELOPING NEW SIX INSULIN
STRIPING ON ITS ROADWAYS.
THESE PERMANENT THERMOPLASTIC
TRY STRIPES ENHANCE NIGHTTIME
VISIBILITY AND HAVE A LONGER
LIFESPAN WHICH REDUCES LIFE
CYCLE COSTS IN REDUCES WORKER
SAFETY CONCERNS --
ALSO BEGINNING TO APPLY NEW
TECHNOLOGY THAT WAS ENGAGE WITH
DURING OUR MERCH REPLACEMENT THE
FIVE FOR CANYON BRIDGE IN BIG
SUR ALLOWED CALTRANS TO
CONSTRUCT THIS PROJECT WITHIN
EIGHT MONTHS.
THIS ENTAILED AN ACCELERATED
BRIDGE REPLACEMENT WHICH PRE
FABRICATED MULTIPLE BRIDGE
ELEMENTS REDUCING CONSTRUCTION
TIME IN A MONTH IN MINIMIZING
IMPACTS TO THE ENVIRONMENT.
IN ADDITION TO PROVING PAYMENT
SB ONE IS ALSO IMPROVING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE.
CALTRANS IS ALREADY BROUGHT ON A
THOUSAND NEW EMPLOYEES AND AS
PART OF THIS YEAR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET IS LOOKING TO HIRE MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED MAIN ITS
WORKERS.
THESE MAIN HIS POSITIONS A KEY
PART OF OUR ASSET MANAGER
STRATEGY ADDRESS BE.
ONE BUT THEY'RE ALSO A GREAT
FIRST STEP OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THOSE WITH NONTRADITIONAL
BACKGROUNDS INCLUDING
HOMELESSNESS INCARCERATION.
CALTRANS IS HARD MORE THAN
SEVENTY PARTICIPANTS OF OUR
PAROLE YOU WORK CREW.
PROGRAM IS PERMANENT AND MAIN
ITS EMPLOYEES.
CALTRANS FREQUENTLY HOLD HIRING
FAIRS ACROSS THE STATE AND WE
ARE HAPPY TO PARTNER WITH
LEGISLATORS.
AND HOSTING EVENTS IN YOUR
COMMUNITIES.
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS CALTRANS IS ALSO
INVESTING IN WORK FORCE
DEVELOPMENT DESIGNED TO INCREASE
THE PARTICIPATION OF
HISTORICALLY UNDERREPRESENTED
GROUPS AND HIGHWAY CONSTRUCTION
SKILLED SCRAPS SKILLED CRAFTS.
WE RULED OUT A FEDERALLY FUNDED
IRONWORKERS BOOT CAMP LAST
AUGUST IN THIS MONTH WE BEGAN A
WOMAN ONLY BUT CAMP TO CURSE
FEMALE PARTICIPATION IN THIS
HISTORICALLY MALE FIELD.
CALTRANS IS CONTRACTING WITH THE
SOUTH A WORKFORCE INVESTMENT
BOARD TO PROVIDE PRE
APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING.
UPON SUCCESSFUL COMPLETION
GRADUATES WILL BE ENROLLED IN
LOCAL PRESSURE PROGRAMS AND
EMPLOYMENT.
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CALTRANS
ENGAGING LADDERS OF
OPPORTUNITIES WHICH IS A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT BETWEEN
CALTRANS CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY LOS ANGELES AND LONG
BEACH DEPARTMENT OF WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT.
THE MAIN OBJECTIVE OF THIS
PROGRAM IS TO INCREASE OVERALL
PARTICIPATION OF MINORITIES
WOMEN AND DISADVANTAGED
INDIVIDUALS IN THE HIGHWAY
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY.
THE SPRING CALTRANS WE WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH ELECTRICIANS UNION
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND THE
OPERATING ENGINEERS UNION OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO SPONSOR
PREMISES.
CALTRANS ALSO MAKING CONCERTED
EFFORT TO REACH SMALL BUSINESS
AND DIVERSE BUSINESSES BUT I'VE
NEVER BEFORE CONTRACTED WITH
CALTRANS.
WE MET THE ETHNIC SPECIFIC
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE PROVIDING NETWORK IN
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES TO SMALL
BUSINESSES.
AND ADVERTISE PROJECTS IN
SPECIALIZED PUBLICATIONS SAYS
THOSE SERVING THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY.
AGAIN WE ARE HAPPY TO PARTNER
WITH MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
IN HOSTNG FORMS TO INCREASE
TRAINING AND REACH FOR SMALL
BUSINESS.
SO FAR IN THE CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR.
CALTRANS IS AWARDED OVER 17% OF
FEDERALLY FUNDED CONTRACT
DOLLARS TO CERTIFIED
DISADVANTAGED BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE.
ALONG WITH 34% OF ALL STAKE THE
CERTIFIED SMALL BUSINESSES.
AND THREE POINT 4% TO DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS ENTERPRISE.
THESE EFFORTS ARE BRINGING THE
POSITIVE IMPACTS OF S.
ONE IN STATE CONTRACTING TO MORE
CALIFORNIANS THAN EVER BEFORE
AND WE ARE WORKING TO CONTINUE
EXPANDING THESE OPPORTUNITIES AS
OUR WORKLOAD CONTINUES TO GROW.
OVERALL I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THE TRANSFORMATIVE SUCCESS SB
ONES HAVE FOR CALTRANS IN LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
CALTRANS IS COMMITTED TO
BUILDING ON THESE RESULTS EVEN
MORE IN THE COMING YEARS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
SURE THESE ACHIEVEMENTS AND I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE --
THANK YOU PANELISTS THE I THINK
WE'LL START WITH QUESTIONS I HAD
I HAD ONE NO I'M.
TERMS OF THE INITIAL.
OUR APPROACH OF GATHERING.
FORCES TO INCREASE EFFICIENCY.
OF A CALTRANS --
THE PANELISTS MAYBE CAN DISCUSS.
HOW WE CAN DO BETTER JOB
INCREASING EFFICIENCY A CALTRANS
AND -- MAYBE
FROM CHAD STANDPOINT THE TRANSIT.
A SYSTEMS WE WANT INCREASE
PERFORMANCE EFFICIENCY ARE THERE
ANY --
EFFORTS WE NEED --
TO UNDERTAKE --
TO INCREASE EFFICIENCY THAT
COULD.
IS NEEDED IN TERMS OF THE
LEGISLATION AND BUDGET OR OR
REGULATIONS THAT WE NEED OUT --
GAPS IN OUR IN OUR WORK THAT WE
STARTED WITH SP --
ONE PALACE COULD COMMENT ON THAT.
I THINK THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
REVIEWING.
THE A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IS
THAT CORRECT HONOR WE WE SERVICE
THE TARGET UNDER MILLION.
DOLLARS A YEAR OF SAVINGS.
AND YOU REVIEW THAT THEY'RE SURE
RIGHT YES THEY THEY CAN'T YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT DID YOU
THINK OF THAT THAT WAS THE FIRST
YEAR WE DO.
SO WHAT IT WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
THAT IS THERE ARE OTHER THINGS
WE NEED TO DO --
WHAT?
CSO THE END AS YOU NOTED THAT
THE CALTRANS IS REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT IT TO THE COMMISSION THE
COMMISSION DOESN'T HAVE AN
APPROVAL ROLE --
BUT BUT WE DID YOU REVIEW IT WE
WERE MITCHELL DRAFTING GAVE SOME
FEEDBACK --
THERE WERE --
THERE WERE A LOT OF THINGS
CALTRANS IS DOING THERE THERE
ARE QUITE A FEW OTHER THINGS
WHICH CALTRANS IS DOING IN AS A
JUST STARTED TO QUANTIFY THEY'VE
DONE EVEN THEY HAVE OTHER THINGS
WHICH THEY HAVEN'T QUANTIFIED AS
WELL BUT HAVE STAND STILL BE
ABLE.
TO ARTICULATE AS EFFICIENCIES
AND WE HAVE ENCOURAGE THEM TO
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THOSE --
INCLUDING SOME OF THE EFFORTS
WHICH MAY NOT HAVE IS --
AS BIG OF A DOLLAR AMOUNT WITH
THEM BUT ARE IMPORTANT JUST IN
NEW YORK IF THERE IF YOU'RE ABLE
TO CUT DOWN THE PA THE
PROCESSING OF SOME ME A PAPER
THAT THAT GETS SUBMITTED BY.
FROM FORTY FIVE DAYS TO TWO
WEEKS IT MAY NOT OUT A LOT BUT
IT'S IT'S AN IMPORTANT FISH AND
SEE -- THEIR
NUMBER OF A A THEIR THINGS THAT
I I THINK --
WE COULD DO JUST AS A STATE ONE
OF THE COMMISSION'S
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE --
IS --
FOCUSED ON AND RESEARCH AT THAT
SPARK SOME OF WHICH IS FUNDED BY
SB ONE AND SOME WHICH HAS OTHER
FUNDING AND THE IDEA OF CREATING
SOME KIND OF CLEARING HOUSE I
THINK THE COMMISSION WE WE COULD
PLAY A ROLE IN THAT.
BUT WHERE THAT WHERE THAT TYPE
OF INFORMATION COULD BE SHARED
ON RESEARCH THAT'S DONE BY
UNIVERSITIES RESEARCH HAS COME
BY CALTRANS.
ED AND SHARED WITH THE PEOPLE AT
COMMISSION MEETINGS AS THESE ARE
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE WHO ARE GOING
TO IMPLEMENT THEM AND AT IN
ACTUALLY.
IN CHARGE OF FUNDING PROJECTS
THERE WERE CERTAIN TO SEE THE
RESEARCH COME OUT THERE THEY'RE
BEGINNING TO FINISH.
SOME OF THOSE RESEARCH PROJECTS
THAT WE'RE INITIALLY FOUND WITH.
WISPY WONDERS OTHER PEOPLE HAVE
COLLEGE OUT OF YOUR ACCOUNT.
YES --
WITHIN WITHIN OUR TRANSIT IN
ZERO CAPITAL PROGRAM MANY OF THE
TYPES OF CAPITAL PROJECTS
AGENCIES ARE PURSUING HELP MAKE
THEIR SYSTEMS MORE EFFICIENT ON
SOME OF THOSE --
OPERATIONS SAVINGS ARE THEN
REINVESTED IN BETTER ERVICES
THE FURTHER GROW THE RIDERSHIP
AND REVENUES OF THE SYSTEM AND
SO THAT THAT IS ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT WE GIVE CREDIT TO AS
AGENCIES ARE ARE TRYING TO LOOK
FOR WAYS TO MAKE THEIR SYSTEMS
MORE EFFICIENT.
WE ALSO ENCOURAGE MUCH OF THE
INTEGRATION BETWEEN SYSTEMS AND
CAP PLANNING TOGETHER ON HOW TO
MAKE --
TRANSIT AND RAIL COORDINATE WELL
IN REGIONS IN THAT THAT ALSO
COMES INTO THE AREA OF IMPROVING
THE EFFICIENCY OF THE OVERALL
SYSTEM.
SORRY --
ANYBODY ELSE WANT TO COMMENT ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT AS I
MENTIONED REMARKS AS WE HAVE
STATE LAW.
CONTINUES OUR SOVEREIGN IMMUNITY
TO THE END OF THE YEAR AT THE
END OF THE YEAR WE LOSE THAT AND
THENTHE ASSIGNMENT GOES AWAY
WITHOUT SOME TYPE OF ADDITIONAL
LAW.
OKAY THAT'S RELATED TO NEPA.
YES SIR OKAY --
THAT'S ON OUR LIST OKAY WE DID
THAT ONCE BEFORE WE EXTENDED OUT.
SO I THINK THAT'S OF NO FOUR ON
THE LIST.
YEAH RIGHT ON ONE THING I WOULD
ADD IS -- A
LOT OF THE SAVINGS THAT ARE
IDENTIFIED A REALLY RELATED TO
TIME.
AND AND NOT HAVING DELAYS AND SO
WHAT WE'VE --
KIND OF PUSHED ON IN OUR
DISCUSSIONS ON THE EFFICIENCIES
THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED SO FAR
IS WHERE OF FEES THAT SAID IN A
FIGHT AS AN EFFICIENT.
A MEASURE FOR THE TIME IS
SHORTENED THERE IS TO REALLY
LOOK AT THE ENTIRE LENGTH OF THE
PROJECT AND IF YOU'RE LOSING
TIME SOMEWHERE ELSE.
MAYBE ARE NOT ACHIEVING THE
GREATEST EFFICIENCY OVER ALL SO
I THINK WE YOU KNOW WE'RE TRYING
TO PUSH A LITTLE HARDER ON A
LOOKING AT THE END ENTIRE LENGTH
OF SOMETHING --
NOT JUST MAKING PARTICULAR PHASE
A SHORTER HE EXPEDITED.
I I HAVE ONE MORE QUESTION --
MAYBE --
CHAD AND JIM PROBABLY WOULDN'T
KNOW THIS --
ONE ONE OF THE RESEARCH PROJECTS
IS BEING DONE BY UC AND SEE A
SHOE IS THE SERVER PAYMENT
MATERIALS ISSUE.
AND THEY'RE DOING RESEARCH ON
LONGER LASTING PAVEMENT IF YOU
WANT TO SET THAT WAY --
I KNOW CALTRANS HAS ITS OWN
RESEARCH --
THAT'S BEEN DONE ON THAT --
IF WE GET PAYMENT TO LAST LONGER.
OF THE WEAR AND TEAR OR IS
BETTER AND IT IS SOME
IMPROVEMENTS SURROUND ON THAT IS --
AN EFFICIENCY.
OF CAN YOU GIVE US SOME
INFORMATION ON THAT ISSUE.
WHAT'S CALTRANS UP TO ON A SURE
CENTER WITH THE WHO HAS TO LAST
LONGER WE PUT IT DOWN THIS WAY
PUT IT SOMETIMES. ONE OF THINGS
I THINK WITH A DELEGATION OF THE
WORK TO THE DISTRICTS AND
DEFINING THAT WORK.
THEY'RE STARTING TO LOOK AT
THREE QUARTERS AND LOOK AT WHERE
IS THE BEST PLACE TO PUT A LONG
LASTING PAVEMENT.
LONG LASTING PAYMENT IS MUCH
MORE EXPENSIVE AND SO WE HAVE TO
LOOK FROM A LIFE CYCLE COST
PERSPECTIVE MASS TO BE EVALUATED
ON INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS BUT WE
ARE PRUDENTLY TRYING TO PUT THAT
IN THE PROPUESTAS FOR THAT AND
SO.
THERE'S SOME BIG GAINS ARE
COMING WITH THE RESEARCH AUTUMN
DAVID.
YEAH OKAY THANK YOU --
ANY A GROVE SIR MCGUIRE --
SENATORS THE SENATORS WHO CHAIR
IN DEAD YOU WANNA TAKE A MOMENT
SAY THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR.
FOR ALL HIS WORK OBVIOUSLY WITH
SB -- ONE IN
ONE OF OUR PANELISTS USED THE
TERM GAME CHANGER AND IT'S BEEN
AN ABSOLUTE GAME CHANGER
SPECIALLY RULE CALIFORNIA --
AND I DO WANNA SAY HOW GRATEFUL
WE ARE TO THE WORK OF BOTH AT
LEAST IN OUR NECK OF THE WOODS
DISTRICT FOR DISAPPOINTING
DISTRICT TO CALTRANS.
AS YOU LOOK AT THESE LONG TERM
LEGACY PROJECTS HAVE NEVER BEEN
ABLE BE TOUCHED BECAUSE OF THE
LACK OF FUNDING AND NOW.
THEY'RE FINALLY ABLE TO START
MOVING BUILT A WE DO MISS AT
MISTER DAVIS IN --
IN DISTRICT --
FOUR IN HIGHWAY THIRTY SEVEN IS
STILL HOT MESS SO --
I THINK THE STORM REALLY DID A
NUMBER ON AYE WAVE. SEVEN ON
EXACTLY -- A
LOT OF WORK BETTER PROBLEMS --
AS WE JUST HEARD FROM MISTER
SNYDER IS READY THAT FIX IT FROM
THE OPERATING ENGINEERS --
RIO.
LOOK --
FIFTY NINE BILLION DOLLAR
BACKLOG ON IT STATE HIGHWAYS AND
BRIDGES SEVEN NINE BILLION
DOLLARS LOCAL ROADS AND STREETS --
IT'S GONNA TAKE TIME AND WANT TO
BE ABLE --
TO TO HEAR FROM YOU ABOUT
EXPECTATIONS I THINK THERE'S A
LOTOF EXPECTATION NOW WE HAVE
FUNDS THAT THEY'RE GONNA STE
THAT FOLKS ARE GONNA START SEEN.
PROJECTS FIXED OVER NIGHT I DO
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO AT THE
CDC S. CDC REALLY HELPS MAKE IT
ALL HAPPEN.
IN A TO YOUR TEAM TO MISS
BRANSON --
FOR POLAND MAGIC AND A HAT.
MANY TIMES THERE'S BEEN A HUGE
AS WELL HE'S GOING TO GET TO
CLOVERDALE --
CALTRANS.
THE CONCERN IN REGARDS TO BEING
COMPETITIVE IN THIS HOT JOB
MARKET.
SO YOU JUST MENTIONED --
ANY OF THE BRING IN INDIVIDUALS
WHO WERE PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED.
AT LEAST IN DISTRICT FOUR AS YOU
KNOW AND THE BAY AREA.
CAN I GET UP FOLKS TO PICK UP
LATER LET ALONE --
DRIVE EQUIPMENT --
AND THEY ARE BEING POACHED FROM
PRIVATE BUSINESS NIGHT --
WITH BETTER PAY TO LIKE TO GO TO
HEAR ABOUT A STRATEGY --
WHAT THIS LOOKS LIKE BECAUSE I
DO THINK THERE'S SOME?
LONG TERM CHALLENGES WITHIN THE
RANKS OF CALTRANS OF BEING ABLE
TO NOT JUST ATTRACTED TO RETAIN.
A HEAVY EQUIPMENT OPERATORS AND
OR GETTING FOLKS INTO THE DOOR.
FOR AN ENTRY LEVEL JOBS AND THEN
WORKING THEIR WAY UP TO THE
CAREER --
TODAY.
THIS DAVIS THE COUNTER.
THANK YOU CENTER YOU KNOW WITH
THINGS --
TOOK.
DIRECTOR TONY DEVICE PENSIVE IN
YOUR NECK OF THE WOODS.
IS LOOKING AT DROUGHT BRING IN
FOLKS FROM THE EAST BAY AND
HIRING THEM IN THE EAST BAY IN
TRAVEL IN OUR TIME TO GET OVER
THERE TO DO WORK IN YOUR
PARTICULAR AREA AS A WAY TO HELP
ADDRESS THIS AT LEAST IN THE
INTERIM.
THAT'S WHEN A MAJOR WAYS WERE
DOING THAT CURRENTLY.
I THINK AND ALL USE THIS AS A WE
USE HIGHWAY THIRTY SEVEN FOR
EXAMPLE.
JUST THE HEAVY EQUIPMENT THERE
ARE NOT ENOUGH A AND I'M NOT
PICKING ON DISTRICT FOR KIDS BY
THE WAY I THINK.
I DISTRICT FOR THEY TRY TO MAKE
EVERYTHING HAPPEN AND TRY TO GET
YES AND AND SINCERE ABOUT THAT
BUT I THINK THERE'S ALSO.
REAL CHALLENGES AND THAT IS
BEING ABLE TO ATTRACTED THE
CURRENT SCALE.
OF WAGES QUALIFIED FOLKS TO
BETTER DRIVE HEAVY EQUIPMENT
THERE'S NO WAY THAT WE CAN
CURRENTLY.
ON COMPETE WITH PRIVATE WHICH IS
NO WAY.
I IN A HAS COME UP TIME AND TIME
AGAIN ON EMERGENCY PROJECTS --
ADDIS.
LONGER LOCAL GOVERNMENT EVEN OR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT SPECIALLY
COUNTY TIMES LOCAL GOVERNOR
[inaudible]
I LOOK.
NO ONE WANTS.
ON GOVERNMENT WORKERS TO MAKE A
LOT OF MONEY I SAY THOUGH WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON PAY.
I KNOW THERE IS A LOT OF CONCERN
ABOUT THAT ANY TO SING TIME
THOUGH -- WE
HAVE TO BECOME MORE COMPETITIVE.
AND BY THE WAY I THINK THE
TAXPAYER BENEFITS --
NGUYEN UP PUBLIC EMPLOYEES ARE
PAID A LIVABLE WAGE SO.
LONG TERM PLANS JUST FROM THE
PANEL ON THIS BECAUSE I THINK IT
IS A IT'S A REAL CONCERN ACROSS
THE STATE NOT JUST IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA BY THINK
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ENTRY LEVEL.
IN BEING ABLE TO RETAIN
EMPLOYEES --
WE SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE THE BAND
WITH AT THIS TIME WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT
[inaudible] FOR NOT.
BUT SERRA TO MAKE SOME GREAT
POINTS.
MS WELL HIGH DIEM A HATE --
MCGUIRE YOU KNOW IT SB ONE JUST.
TO SB ONE WHEN WE WROTE IT PUT A
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS INTO THE
WAR THE STATE WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT BOARD. TO LEAD THE
EFFORT TO HIRE THE SEVENTY
THOUSAND JOBS THAT IS B. ONE
CREATED SO THE THE YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
QUITMAN OPERATORS ALL THERE'S A
WHOLE WIDE RANGE OF JOBS THAT
ARE BEING CREATED AND OBVIOUSLY.
WE WANT THOSE JOBS TO BE FOR OUR
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS NOT.
SOMEBODY LIVES IN SOME OTHER
STATE WE WANT TO KEEP THE JOBS.
FOR OUR OUR RESIDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA TO HAVE THOSE JOBS SO
SO THE WORKFORCE INVESTMENT.
BOARD.
THE INVESTMENT --
TRANSPORTATION FUNDS.
WAS TO CREATE A UP --
INCREASING THE POOL OF QUALIFIED
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS TO WORK ON
TRANSPORTATION.
AND KEEP THE PAY ROLL IF YOU
WANT TO SAY IT THAT WAY IN
CALIFORNIA SO.
THOSE PEOPLE BE BUYING GROCERIES
IN CALIFORNIA NINE TEXAS OR
SOMEPLACE I I TOTALLY --
SO THAT THAT'S DEBTS BUT THE
QUESTION IS LIKE IF THERE'S SUB --
WE JUST THE NUMBER JUST GOT PUT
IN THERE BE HONEST ABOUT IT.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE NUMBERS
ENOUGH.
IT MAY BE THE FOR A SHORTER TIME
WE ON INCREASE THAT.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHY --
IN TERMS OF A POLICY.
MAYBE --
THIS SPECTER GENERAL OR THE
TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY CAN AND
MAYBE GIVE US SOME ADVICE ABOUT.
WHETHER OR NOT WE NEED TO HAVE A
INCREASE IN THE LEVEL OF FUNDING
FOR THIS JOB TRAINING.
ELEMENT.
TO GET ENOUGH WORKERS BECAUSE IF
YOU DON'T HAVE ENOUGH WORKERS SO
USERS CAN SLOW THE PROJECTS DOWN.
INTO PROJECTS COULD SLOW DOWN
THEN THEY YOU KNOW THEY'RE GOING
TO COST MORE THERE'S ONE THING
YOU CAN DO TO MAKE PROJECTS
COSTS MORE.
IN A SLOWER PROJECT DOWN.
IF YOU INCREASE THE TIMING ON
THE PROJECT THE SPEED OF THE
PROJECT.
THE COSTS LAST SO HAVING WORKERS
SAVES MONEY ACTUALLY TRAINING
WORKERS SAVES MONEY.
IT'S PART YOU KNOW SO I DON'T
SOME REQUIRE.
YOU YOU NEED THOSE PROJECT
EMERGENCY IT'S ALMOST RIGHT TO
LEAN IN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I THINK MY BOTTOM LINE
IS THIS.
I THINK ON THE CALTRANS SITE.
THEY NEED TO BE A LONGER TERM
STRATEGY ABOUT.
HOW WE'RE GOING TO ATTRACT AND
RETAIN THE BUDGET --
BECAUSE IT IT IS OF GREAT
CONCERN ESPECIALLY ON FOR
EXAMPLE WE ARE NOT COMPETITIVE
ANY LONGER AND SOME THE CLERICAL
ADMINISTRATIVE.
WE ARE BEYOND.
THE SCOPE WHEN IT COMES TO BEING
COMPETITIVE WITH PRIVATE
INDUSTRY FOR HEAVY EQUIPMENT
OPERATORS.
AND IT DOES LEAVE INFRASTRUCTURE
VULNERABLE ESPECIALLY ON THOSE
EMERGENCY JOBS --
IF WE ARE NOT ABLE TO BE TO GET
OUR OWN FOLKS OUT THERE --
IN AGAIN I KNOW THAT COULD BE
CONTROVERSIAL AT TIMES BUT I
THINK --
ESPECIALLY IN THIS JOB MARKET IN
MANY AREAS OF THE STATE.
WE ARE VULNERABLE FOR NOT PAYING
A STATE WORKERS ARE COMPETITIVE
WITH PRIVATE ON IN ALSO WANTED
BETTER DRIED THE BEST DEAL FOR
THE TAXPAYER OBVIOUSLY INTO WHAT
IS THAT LONG TERM STRATEGY INTO
START TO SERVE.
AND TO CARRY ANY ITEM AND ANY
THOUGHTS THAT YOU HAVE.
YES WELL I MEAN I I THINK WE'D
BE GLAD TO GET BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE WITH MORE INFORMATION
ON THIS ON THIS TOPIC AND SOME
OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS WOULD
APPRECIATE IT SO THAT WOULD BE
GREAT.
WORK ON THE TRANSIT AND RAIL
SIDE WE REALLY TRY TO WORK AT
THE RIGHT LEVEL OF BALANCING
WHAT WE CAN DO WITH THE STATE
WHAT WE CAN DO AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND SO SOMETIMES THAT
PARTNERSHIP HELPS ADDRESS THIS
ON THOSE TYPES OF PROJECTS BUT I
THINK ON THE BROADER.
ISSUE OF CALTRANS WOULD BE GLAD
TO GET THAT GREAT AND THIS IS
THE LAST COMMENT MISTER CHAIRS
THIS AGAIN AS WELL AS A THANK
YOU. TO CALTRANS THEY ARE
HUSTLING --
ALL THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
TRYING TO BE A TO GET PROJECTS
MOVED.
VERY VERY GRATEFUL ALONG WITH
THE CDC TO BE ABLE TO GET THE
MONEY OUT THERE --
AND DO APPRECIATE THE TEAM WORK --
INTO THE CALTRANS A CREW WERE
HERE AS WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH --
AND PLEASE PASS AND THANKS TO
THE DIRECTOR.
QUESTIONS FOR ME MEMBERS.
THANK YOU PANELISTS WILL GO OVER
THE NEXT PANELIST WILL HAVE --
MORE OF A LOCAL --
PERSPECTIVE THE NEXT PANELIST
WILL HAVE --
DARRYL JOHNSON'S COMING IN FROM
ORANGE COUNTY DURRELL'S HERE.
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY.
RONI RUNNING FOR DOES THE LEAD
LEAD --
TRANSPORTATION ADVOCATE FOR THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES --
HECTOR BROWN AS DIRECTOR PUBLIC
WORKS HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
HE'S BUSY TODAY I GUESS ON A
BUSY TODAY IN TERMS OF OUR
WEATHER SITUATION --
IS NOT IS WORKING OKAY HE'S NOT
HERE.
KIRKUK IS FROM --
SAN LEANDRO.
AND MARK WHAT SIR FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA.
ORGANIZATION SO. THREE WANT TO
GET EVERYBODY LINED UP.
HECTOR AFECTAR IS OUT WORKING OR
ILL RIGHT IS NOT WELL TODAY
[inaudible]
SO.
OKAY I BELIEVE WE'RE GONNA START
WITH GERALD THE JOHNSON FROM --
ORANGE COUNTY ãNSPORTATION
AUTHORITY.
AND WELCOME GIRL THANKS FOR
COMING UP TO SACRAMENTO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERY
HAPPY TO BE HERE --
IS --
RAINING HERE IT'S NOT IN ORANGE
COUNTY TODAY WHICH WERE VERY
HAPPY ABOUT FOR EIGHT DAYS.
AGAIN GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CHERYL
JOHNSON AND THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FOR THE ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY.
AND FIRST AND FOREMOST THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
ABOUT A VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC.
IN AS I THINK YOU KNOW OCC IS
ONE OF ONLY BRITISH AUTHORITIES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
BETWEEN US LOS ANGELES COUNTY OF
SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
THEY GIVE THIS UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE ON TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS AND PROGRAMS.
THAT WE SEE EACH AND EVERY DAY.
FOR THE PRIMARY TRANSPORTATION
PROVIDER FOR FUNDING PLAN IN
IMPLEMENTING COUNTY BY BUS AND
RAIL SERVICE FREEWAY
IMPROVEMENTS FOR THE OWNER AND
OPERATOR OF THE NINETY ONE
EXPRESS LANES WERE CURRENTLY
BUILDING THE I FOUR OR FIVE
EXPRESS LANES.
WE MANAGED RETURN ROAD
IMPROVEMENTS WE FIND METROLINK
RAIL IN WE DO OTHER PROGRAMS AS
WELL -- MOST
OF OUR PROGRAMS ARE MADE
POSSIBLE THROUGH AN ALLOCATION
OF BOTH FEDERAL AND STATE
DOLLARS AS WELL AS OUR LOCAL
SALES TAX KNOWN AS MEASURE RAM.
WHICH IS OUR HAVE SINCE
TRANSPORTATION SALES TAX.
AS IT RELATES TO SB ONE FOR SOME
LIKE TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE BROADER PERSPECTIVE THE
MAYBE HONE IN A LITTLE BIT ON
TRANSIT --
THAT THE BROADER PERSPECTIVE
CLEARLY YOU'VE HEARD FROM THE
PREVIOUS PANEL ABOUT WHAT THAT
DOES AND IT'S REALLY HELPED US
LEVERAGE OUR EXISTING
TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS
INSTRUCTION FURTHER AND MAKE
THOSE INVESTMENTS GO LONGER. TO
DOUBLE THE FUNDING --
AT THE CITY LEVEL FOR EACH AND
EVERYONE OF OUR THIRTY FOUR
CITIES IN ORANGE COUNTY AND IT'S
FUNDED --
DOUBLED OUR FUNDING FOR THE
COUNTY ROAD SYSTEM AS WELL.
IS PROVIDED TO STABILITY TO THE
STEP WHICH IS VERY IMPORTANT
FUNDING SOURCE FOR COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES.
CAN IT'S ALLOWED US TO SUPPORT
OUR AND INVESTMENT IN SUPPORT IN
THE PACIFIC SURFLINER SERVICE
WHICH CONNECTS SAN DIEGO ORANGE
COUNTY LOS ANGELES MUCH AS YOU
HEARD FROM MISTER ADDISON A
MOMENT AGO. TO DATE --
OCD IS EITHER PROGRAM TO BEEN
AWARDED JUST UNDER FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AND SB ONE
FUNDING.
IN SPECIFICALLY IS NOT
EXHAUSTIVE LIST BUT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS ON THE
I FIVE ON STATE ROUTE FIFTY
SEVEN STATE ROUTE.
FIFTY FIVE WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
PURCHASE NEW TRANSIT BUSES AND
MAKE --
IMPROVEMENTS THAT ARE BUT BASS
OPERATING BASES WITH ABLE TO DO
ACTED TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS
AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO WORK ON
OUR TRAFFIC SIGNAL
SYNCHRONIZATION PROGRAM WHICH
REALLY I LIKE TO THINK OF THAT
IS IS GETTING MORE BANG FOR YOUR
BUCK OUT OF YOUR EXISTING SYSTEM
TAKING WHAT YOU HAVE.
IN MAKING IT WORK BETTER BY
LEVERAGING TECHNOLOGY.
JUST FOR A MOMENT WHEN A MOVE TO
WHAT I THINK IS THE MOST
CRITICAL IMMEDIATE BENEFITS THAT
ACCRUED TO THE ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY TO THE
BROADER RESIDENTS OF ORANGE
COUNTY BECAUSE OF SB.
ONE AND THAT WAS THE TRANSIT
FUNDING PROVIDED WITHIN SB --
ONE CITY IS THE FIFTH LARGEST
BUS OPERATOR IN THE STATE A LOT
OF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THAT WE
CARRIED FORTY EIGHT MILLION
PEOPLE LAST YEAR.
WE HAVE A LARGE BUS FLEET OF
FIVE HUNDRED BUSES IN A PARA
TRANSIT FLEET OF TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY EIGHT BUSES.
PRIOR TO THE PASSAGE OF SB ONE
WE HAD WENT IN FRONT OF OUR
BOARD OF DIRECTORS AND TALKED
ABOUT 11% DECREASE IN OUR
TRANSIT OPERATIONS A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND SERVICE HOURS.
THAT WOULD HAVE INVOLVED --
REDUCING PARA TRANSIT SERVICE
FIXED ROUTE OPERATIONS SERVICE
AND LAYOFFS OF KEY EMPLOYEES --
IN IN OUR SERVICE AREA AS WE
FRANKLY TO IT'S GOING.
SB ONE REALLY SAVED THE DAY THAT
ALLOWED US NOT ONLY.
TO KEEP AT THAT LEVEL OF SERVICE
IN PLACE BUT IT ALLOWED US TO
COMPLETELY REDO HOW WE THOUGHT
ABOUT TRANSIT SERVICE IN THE
COUNTY AND THAT WAS A MEDIA THAT
DIDN'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH.
AN APPROVAL PROCESS AT A LATER
DATE IT WAS IN THE EXISTING
PROGRAM IT ALLOWED US TO KEEP
THE SERVICE GO IN IT ALLOWED US
TO REPLACE AGING BOSSES AND MAKE
INVESTMENTS --
INTO OUR TRANSIT OPERATIONS --
BASIS -- AS
WELL.
IT ALLOWED US TO BUY ZERO
EMISSION BUS PURCHASES TO EXPAND
SERVICE ON MAIN STREET BETWEEN
ANAHEIM IN COSTA MESA WHICH IS A
KEY PART.
OF OUR COUNTY --
ININ ORANGE COUNTY.
THE TRANSIT FUNDING --
ONE ONE OF THE REASONS IT
PROVIDED SUCH IMMEDIATE BENEFIT
IS THROUGH THE FOUR SITES OF THE
PROGRAM IT WAS FORMULA BASED
WHICH IS VERY IMPORTANT.
BUT IT ALSO IS PROVIDED THROUGH
AN EXISTING PROGRAM THAT
PROGRAMS THE STATE TRANSIT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
IN IS ALLOWED FOR US TO GO VERY
CLEARLY BECAUSE WE UNDERSTOOD
THE FUNDING FOR FLEXIBILITY THE
REQUIREMENTS THE RESTRICTIONS IN
THE METRICS.
SO WE COULD PUT THE DOLLARS TO
WORK RIGHT AWAY.
CONCURRENT TO THAT IT ALSO
ALLOWED US TO MAKE PROGRESS ON
OUR CORE TRANSIT SERVICE AREA IS
PART OF OUR OVERALL A
COMPREHENSIVE OPERATIONS PLAN ON
THIS BUS.
THREE SIXTY WE REALLOCATED
SERVICE WITHIN THE WITHIN THIS
WITHIN THE COURSE SERVICE AREA
SO INSTEAD OF CUTTING SERVICE
WERE ABLE TO ADD SERVICE AS A
RESULT OF SB.
ONE LOOKING FORWARD --
THE FUTURE SB ONE FUNDS WE
BELIEVE WILL FOR FLEXIBILITY IN
OUR FIVE A PLANNING AND FUNDING
EFFORTS --
BOTH FOR CAPITAL AND OPERATING
EXPENSES AND THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT AS A TRANSIT OPERATOR.
THIS WOULD ALLOW US TO EXPAND
POTENTIALLY EXPAND OUR TRANSIT
SERVICE IN HIGH DEMAND QUARTERS.
OF CORNERS AND SERVE NOT ONLY
ARE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
OUR LONG COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO
FOR THOSE THAT ARE IN OUR
REGIONAL PLANS IN SUPPORT.
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTIONS.
IN CONCLUSION I COULD SPEND A
BIT OF TIME TALKING ABOUT ALL
THE THINGS I STREETS ROADS AND
HIGHWAYS BUT I THINK THAT WAS
COVERED QUITE WELL --
BY CALTRANS WE WANNA BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THEM IN THEIR
EFFORTS --
BUT THIS IS HAD A HUGE IMPACT ON
TRANSIT OERATIONS MAINTENANCE
AND CAPITAL --
INVESTMENT IN ORANGE COUNTY TO
THE TRANSIT SYSTEM AND AGAIN
WITH WITHOUT THIS DIRECT
INFUSION WE WOULD BEEN FACED
WITH CUTTING NAY NEARLY 11% OF
OUR SERVICE.
AYE IN A VERY SHORT AMOUNT OF
TIME SO ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE OF
CITIES ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
INVESTMENT IN IMPORTANCE OF SB
ONE AN ORANGE COUNTY.
THANK YOU THANK TO DARRYL A
RUNNY **** RUNNING OF THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE RIGHT VERTIGO HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES --
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US HERE
TODAY I THINK THIS IS A PORN
HEARING --
TO HAVE --
AS YOU ALL KNOW THE LEAGUE AND
THE COALITION OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT --
BUSINESS AND LABOR STAKEHOLDERS
WORKED TIRELESSLY FLETCHER --
AND THE FORMER ADMINISTRATION TO
DELIVER --
THE GREATEST INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE WE SEEN IN A
GENERATION --
I WANT TO THANK CHAIRMAN
BELFORD'S EXHAUSTED LEADERSHIP
TENACITY ENVISIONED YEAR IN AND
YEAR OUT --
INTO IT ALL CAME TOGETHER IN THE
FORM OF A SB ONE IN --
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TRIMMING DOWN
AND SHERMAN FRAZIER --
HAD A CLEAR VISION EARLY ON THAT
A TRANSPORTATION PACKAGE NEEDED
TO DO. THREE THINGS NUMBER.
ONE PROVIDE RELIABLE FUNDING FOR
EVERY MODE OF TRANSPORTATION --
INCLUDING THE STATE HIGHWAY
SYSTEM LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS --
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION CONGESTION RELIEF
IN CAPITAL PROJECTS --
NUMBER TO INCLUDE A SERIES OF
REFORMS --
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR CALTRANS A LOCAL AGENCIES
ALIKE -- TO
ENSURE PROMISES MADE PROMISES
KEPT.
A NUMBER.
THREE INCLUDE CONSTITUTIONAL
PROTECTIONS --
TO ENSURE THE FUNDS CAN ONLY BE
USED FOR TRANSPORTATION AND NOT
FOR ANY OTHER PURPOSE --
THESE ARE THE THREE CORE
ELEMENTS OF THE OVERALL PACKAGE
AND AS SOON AS SB ONE WENT INTO
EFFECT --
CITIES ACROSS THE STATE STEPPED
UP TO THE CHALLENGE THEIR LIST
OF PROJECTS THAT WOULD BE
FINDING WITH THE NEW REVENUE --
AND REPORTED WHERE EVERY SB ONE
DOLLAR WAS SPENT JUST THIS PAST
OCTOBER TO CLOSE OUT THE FISCAL
YEAR.
WHAT'S THE ONE WHICH CHAPTER IN
APRIL COLLECTION YOU REVENUE
SOURCES DID NOT BEGIN UNTIL
NOVEMBER --
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WITH CITY
SEEING THEIR FIRST PAYMENT IN
EARLY --
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THEREFORE
THERE'S JUST BEEN A BIT OVER A
YEAR OF THESE FUNDS --
QUITE LITERALLY HEADING CITY
STREETS --
BUT WORK IS BEING FORMED ACROSS
THE STATE --
WITH HUNDREDS OF PROJECTS
FORECASTED YEARS AHEAD.
AS FOR THE IMPACT OF SB ONE THE
LEAGUE KNOWS --
THROUGH OUR LOCAL SHE THROUGHOUT
THE NEEDS SSESSMENT --
WHICH IS BEEN CONDUCTED EVERY
OTHER YEAR --
FOR THE PAST TEN YEARS THAT THE
IMPACT OF SB ONE IS IMMENSE.
UP INTO OUR MOST RECENT REPORT
THE AT FUNDING NEEDS FOR LOCAL
SHE TO ROADS.
CONSISTENTLY EXCEEDED OVER
SEVENTY BILLION DOLLARS THAT
WOULD HAVE GROWN BY TWENTY
BILLION.
IN TEN YEARS ABSENT ANY NEW
FUNDING.
ON A SCALE OF ZERO TO ONE
HUNDRED THE AVERAGE PAY MY
CONDITION WAS AT SIXTY FIVE
PROJECTED TO SLIDE DOWN TO FIFTY
FIVE TEN YEARS.
SCORE FIFTY FIVE IN THE
CLASSROOM IS AN F. --
WE ALSO KNEW THAT WITHOUT ANY
NEW FUNDING. 49% OF THE LOCAL
NETWORK WOULD HAVE MOVED INTO AN
ACT RISK CONDITION THAT MEANS
THE SCORE BELOW.
SEVENTY ON THE PAVEMENT
CONDITION INDEX.
WITH MORE THAN A QUARTER OF THE
NETWORK MOVING INTO THE FIELD
CONDITION --
WHICH WHICH WE WOULD CATEGORY
CRIES AS AS RED --
WHEN YOU LOOK AT LOOK AT IT ON A
MAP?
WITH SB ONE THAT'S NO LONGER THE
CASE -- THE
I MET FUNDING THE FOR LOCAL SHE
THROWS HAS SHRUNK BY ABOUT
EIGHTEEN BILLION DOLLARS OVER
THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
AND THE AVERAGE PAVEMENT
CONDITION WILL STABILIZE RIGHT
AROUND SCORE OF SIXTY FIVE FOR
THE NEXT TEN YEARS --
MOST IMPORTANTLY --
ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF THE LOCAL
NETWORK WILL MOVE INTO A STATE
OF GOOD REPAIR --
OR SCORE BUT SEVENTIES AS CITIES
AND COUNTIES FOCUS ON A FIX IT%
FOR STRATEGY --
TO MAXIMIZE EVERY PENNY OUT OF
EVERY TRANSPORTATION DOLLAR THAT
THEY RECEIVE [inaudible]
HI.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR SB ONE IS A
GAME CHANGER AS WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER --
WITHOUT IT ARE TRANSPORTATION
NETWORKS WOULD HAVE CONTINUED TO
CRUMBLE --
THERE WAS NEVER AN EXPECTATION
THAT A FUNNY PACKAGE WOULD
ELIMINATE A NEARLY TWO HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLAR --
BACK LOG TO THE STATE AND LOCAL
SYSTEM --
BUT WE KNEW SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT WAS NEEDED TO SEND --
WHAT THE TAXPAYERS HAVE ALREADY
BUILT?
THEREFORE IT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT.
TO ALLOW SB WANT TO TO DO WHAT
IT WAS MEANT TO DO AND TO ALLOW
IT TO GET TO WORK --
AND FOR THIS LEGISLATURE TO
THINK VERY CAREFULLY ABOUT WHAT
WAS ACCOMPLISHED HERE --
INSTEAD OF ATTACHING STRINGS TO
THE FUNDING AS I KNOW --
YOU KNOW THERE MAY BE SOME IDEAS
ABOUT THAT OUT THERE --
WE SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT WAYS
TO STREAMLINED PROJECT DELIVERY --
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY TO REALLY
ENSURE CERTAINTY THAT THESE
FUNDS ARE GOING TO HIT.
THE COMMUNITIES.
LET'S FOCUS ON ENSURING THAT
THERE ARE NO DELAYS TO THESE
FUNDS -- AND
EVERY COMMUNITIES A
TRANSPORTATION SAFETY CONDITION.
AND QUALITY OF LIFE FOR PERMITS --
THAT THEY WERE PROMISED BOTH
DURING THE PASSAGE OF SB --
ONE AND THE DEFEAT OF
PROPOSITION --
SIX SO WITH THAT I'LL CONCLUDE
MY REMARKS AND BE AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OF WILL GO TO PUBLIC WORKS
DIRECTOR. FOR THE ARE YOU SEE IT
TRANSPORTATION DIRECTOR I THINK
YOUR TITLE IS STRICTLY --
CITIES SAN LEANDRO --
MEN LITERALLY ON THE STREETS
EXACTLY YES THANK YOU OKAY LET'S
GO MAYBE I'LL TAKE A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT PRO T<c.cyan> MY NAME IS</c>
KEITH COOK ON THE ENGINEERING
TRANSPORTATION DIRECTOR. FOR THE
CITY SAN LEANDRO --
THAT'S IN SENATE DISTRICT.
NINE AND I'VE BEEN IN THIS
BUSINESS ABOUT TWENTY FIVE YEARS
NOW IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR IN
TRANSPORTATION.
AND I CAN TELL YOU YOU KNOW
FIRST HAND HOW NECESSARY AND
REFRESHING IS TO FINALLY HAVE A
STEADY STREAM.
OF TRANSPORTATION FUNDING TO
MAKE UP FOR THE DECADES OF
NEGLECT ON OUR LOCAL STREETS AND
ROADS.
YOU KNOW --
RUNNY SAID T IS THIS THESE
FUNDS ARE GAME CHANGER --
BUT THEY'RE NOT THE END ALL
UNFORTUNATELY AND I I LIKE TO
MAKE THE EXAMPLE OF UP FOR LIKE
IT'S TOOL.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE --
THE LOCAL FUNDING THAT NEEDS TO
BE IN PLACE.
COUNTY FUNDING THAT NEED TO BE
IN PLACE THE STATE NEEDS TO DO
THEIR PART.
AND EVEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
NEEDS TO DO THEIR BOTH SYSTEMS
TO REALLY BE.
A PUT TOGETHER RIGHT NOW I THINK
WE GOT THREE LEGS OF THAT SCHOOL.
YOU'LL GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION SO AT LEAST WE CAN
BALANCE AND NOT --
YOU KNOW TIP OVER BUT WORK WE
WERE STILL WE'RE STILL SHORT.
AND IT THE THE THE LAST TIME
THERE WAS A STATE INFUSION LOCAL
ROADS AND I CAN REMEMBER IT I
WAS. TWENTY YEARS YOUNGER AND I
PROBABLY UNLESS UNLESS GRAY HERE.
PUT BACK IN THE NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT AND AND A NINETY EIGHT
NINETY NINE AROUND THAT TIME
FRAME.
AND I WOULD I WAS MUCH YOUNGER
OBVIOUSLY I WAS EXCITED AND I
SAID WELL WE'RE GONNA MAKE A
DIFFERENCE BUT YOU KNOW BEING
YOUNG AND REALIZED IT WAS JUST
LIKE A ONE TIME INFUSION.
AND ALTHOUGH WE PUMPED UP A
LITTLE BIT IS STILL STARTED --
TO TO SWIRL DOWN.
AND SO.
IT'S A IT'S ALWAYS BEEN A
CHALLENGE --
AS IT WOULD SEAT FOR THE CITY
SAN LEANDRO THESE FUNDS ARE ARE
JUST NOW.
STARTING TO TRICKLE IN BUT IT'S
AN IMPORTANT PART OF THE WORK
WERE ABLE TO CARRY OUT.
WILL TRY TO GIVE THE FEELING OF
THE MAGNITUDE OF OUR CHALLENGE
SAN LEANDRO THE CITY ABOUT
NINETY ONE THOUSAND SO YOU CAN
GET THIS IN PERSPECTIVE.
THAT WAS INCORPORATED IN
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO SO YOU CAN
IMAGINE THAT SOME OF OUR ROADS.
OUR OUR OLD.
AND ALTHOUGH I DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT WE NEGLECTED OUR ROADS I
THINK THAT OVER TIME WITH
STAGNANT REVENUES.
AND INFLATION OUR ABILITY TO
MAINTAIN OUR ROADS SLOWLY
DETERIORATED ALONG WITH THE
ALONG WITH THE ROADS THEMSELVES
OVER OVER THIS TIME PERIOD --
WE SAW KIND OF A SMALL
RESURGENCE IN THE EIGHTIES AND
AROUND THE NINETIES WHEN ALAMEDA
COUNTY BECAME A SELF HELP --
A COUNTY.
IN THIS KIND OF PUSHED OFF OUR
OUR DOOMSDAY A LITTLE BIT LONGER --
BUT IT WAS STILL GOING TO BE
INEVITABLE BECAUSE THERE JUST
HADN'T BEEN ALL THE ADDITIONAL
GROWTH WE NEED IT --
WE RECENTLY --
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL DECIDED TO
INCREASE OUR SALES TAX.
AND THEN AS PROFESSIONALS AND AS
WE REALLY KNEW THAT WE NEEDED TO
HAVE A A FIX IT FIRST AN AWESOME
PHILOSOPHY AND WHAT WE DID AND
SO.
IN THE SUBSEQUENT --
COUNTY MEASURES AND SALES TAX
LOCAL AND THEN NOW EVEN WITH THE
SP ONE FUNDS WE REALLY TAKEN
THIS TO TO HEART AND REALLY GONE
AFTER -- OUR
OUR LOCAL STREETS IN TRYING TO
REPAIR THEM --
AND SO --
JUST TO MAINTAIN OUR STREETS
CURRENTLY IN OUR IN OUR DISMAL
LEVEL OF OF A PCI.
FIFTY SIX WE NEED APPROXIMATELY
TEN MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR TEN
TO ELEVEN MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
SO YOU CAN SEE THAT YOU KNOW THE
SB ONE IN THE WHO THE MONEY --
BUT ABOUT 25% OF THAT THAT'S ONE
OF THOSE LEGS THAT WERE WERE
STANDING ON WE AS A CITY HAD --
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE PUT OUR
PARTY IN.
AND THEN ALONG WITH THE THE
COUNTY FUNDS OF WE ARE ABLE TO
TO GARNER THOSE FUNDS TOGETHER
AND SO --
THESE LAST YEAR --
AND AND ALSO I THINK THE ONE
THING IS THE CERTAINTY.
OF THAT THE FUNDS COME IN THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO EVEN YOU KNOW TAKE
OUT THE RISK AND PUT EVEN MORE
OF OUR OWN GENERAL FUND MONEY.
INTO THE POT TO TO GO OUT REPAIR
SO THIS YEAR --
WE BECAUSE OF A A LOT OF IT WAS
FROM -- THE
ACTC FUNDS BUT WE DID THIRTY
POINT SEVEN LANE MILES OF OF
PAVING FOR ABOUT ELEVEN POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS.
AND A FIFTEEN POINT FIVE A SEAL
WORK AT ABOUT ALMOST TWO MILLION
DOLLARS.
AND SO.
ALL THAT MONEY COMING TOGETHER
AT THE RIGHT TIME MAKES A
DIFFERENCE AND SO --
WE'RE WE'RE FEELING GOOD RIGHT
NOW THAT WE'RE GOING.
TO TURN OUR OUR BOAT AROUND IT
STILL DOESN'T TURN IT ALL AROUND
BUT WE'RE GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTIONS [inaudible]
AND ALAA WRAP UP HERE SO --
AS THE YOU KNOW THE SB ONE
DEFINITELY WAS --
I'LL YOU KNOW IMPORTANT BILL FOR
US AND AND IN I WANTED TO ADD
THAT THE MOE COMPONENT I THINK
WAS A VERY WISE COMPONENT TO
HAVE IN THAT BILL --
IT JUST KEEPS EVERYBODY TRUE TO
THE NEEDS OF IT'S OF EFFORT YES
MAINTENANCE OF EFFORT SORRY YES.
OF OF THE OF GETTING THE WORK
DONE THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE AND
AND SO I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR MAKING SURE THIS --
THIS WORKING SUPPORT AND TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
KEYS -- THE
SAID OF WILCOX IS PENSION FOR
HECTOR BROWN AND FROM THE CITY
OF SACRAMENTO.
VERY BUSY CITY TODAY.
OKAY LE CENTRE GO AHEAD YOU HAVE
THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU A CHAIR BALLOT MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I'M LISTEN TO
WILCOX I MET ON PROGRAM MANAGER
WITH THE CITY SACRAMENTO AND
HECTOR BROWN OUR PUBLIC WORKS
DIRECTOR APOLOGIZES HE SELLS
THOSE UNABLE TO BE HERE.
AND BUT I'M VERY PLEASED TO BE
HERE ONBEHALF OF THE CITY AND
ITS PUBLIC WORKS DEPARTMENT --
SO SACRAMENTO IS MAYBE WHERE
WE'RE A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
YEAR OLD CITY SO WE HAVE.
THE SANTANDER BEAT AB WITH ABOUT
HALF TEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S BEEN
DEVELOPED OVER THE LAST HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FIVE YEARS.
THAT WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR
MAINTAINING THEM AND KEEPING IN
A STATE OF GOOD REPAIR --
NOT ONLY A ROADWAY NETWORK BUT
OUR BIKE WE SYSTEM ARE TRAFFIC
SIGNALS ARE STREET LIGHTS WE
HAVE FLOOD GATES.
WHICH WERE IMPORTANT AT THIS
TIME -- SO
WE HAVE A LOT OF THEM NEEDSAND
SO I'M GOING OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE.
RECORD THIS MAJORITY OF THE
CITY'S TRANSPORTATION FUNDING.
UNTIL AT WAS HARKEN BACK ABOUT
TWO YEARS AGO AT THIS TIME WE
ARE WORKING ON THE CITY BUDGET
FOR TRANSPORTATION --
IT WAS A REALLY GRIM TIME WHERE
OUR TRANSPORTATION FUNDING HAD
CONTINUE TO DECLINE --
WE HAD JUST NARROWLY MISSED
PASSING A SUPPLEMENTAL.
TRANSPORTATION COUNTY WIDE SALES
TAX MEASURE AND AND SO WITH OUR
BUDGET WE HAD PLANT WE HAD A
BUDGET THE PLANNED ON DOING.
FOCUSING BASICALLY ON EMERGENCY
REPAIRS UNABLE TO DO A LOT OF
PROACTIVE MAINTENANCE AND WE
WERE LOOKING AT HOW WE'RE GONNA
TO FREEZE OUR MAINTENANCE STAFF
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO OVER THE
LONG TERM.
SO AM AND IN THE YEAR BEFORE SB
ONE PASSED WE FILLED TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND POTHOLES APPS SUCH AS
GIVE ME A SENSE OF HOW WE HAD TO
DO SO MUCH EMERGENCY REPAIR.
SO IN THE TWO YEARS SINCE HIS
PAST A LOT HAS CHANGED --
LIKE MOST COMMUNITIES WE HAVE A
IN AND PAVEMENT MAINTENANCE --
WHERE IT ABOUT SIXTY SIX WHICH
IS AROUND THE STATEWIDE AVERAGE?
BUT AND WE FOCUS ON PAVEMENT AND
RUBIO LIKE TO FOCUS THAT IT
REALLY DOES NOT ONLY AFFECT JUST
AUTOMOBILES.
AUTO TRAVEL BUT ALSO OTHER FORMS
OF TRANSPORTATION SO OUR BUSES
ARE CYCLISTS.
NOW OUR SCOOTERS THAT WE HAVE IN
OUR CITIES --
AND IT ALSO IS A REALLY GREAT
OPPORTUNITY A BLANK SLATE TO
READ LOOK AT ALL THE PROBLEMS WE
HAVE WITH OUR STREETS --
AND A RECORD FOR THOSE AT THE
SAME TIME.
SO WHEN WE WHEN SB ONE PASSED
OUR FIRST PRIORITY WAS TO FOCUS
ON PAVEMENT REHABILITATION --
SO WE TOOK THE FORMULA FUNDS AND
THAT THE CITY RECEIVED.
IN ADDITION --
AS A SELF HELP COUNTY SACRAMENTO --
RECEIVED --
SOME FINDING THROUGH.
ARE SOME S. PRIMULA FINDING.
THROUGH THE LOCAL TING IN THE
LOCAL TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM --
AND THE REGION AGREED THAT WE
WOULD DIVIDE THAT UP.
OF PROPORTIONATELY FOR ALL OF
OUR MEMBERS AND ALSO TO FOCUS ON
A PAVEMENT REHABILITATION AND
BASICALLY STATE OF GOOD REPAIR --
WITH A TRANSIT SYSTEM.
AND SO WE M..
TOOK THAT AND WE DECIDED WE WERE
GOING TO DO --
A SUBSTANTIAL EFFORT SO LAST
SPRING AND SUMMER WE WERE ABLE
TO CONTRACT OUT ABOUT TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN PAVEMENT
REHABILITATION PROJECTS --
AND SO THE CITY HAS A CONTRACT
OUT ITS REHAB AND HANDLE THE
INTERNAL AND EMERGENCY REPAIRS
INTERNALLY.
AND WE DECIDED TO CONTACT US
THIS FUNDING INTO FOUR SEPARATE
CONTRACTS FOR A COUPLE OF
REASONS --
FIRST OF ALL WE WANTED TO GET IT
DONE QUICKLY TO REALLY
DEMONSTRATE TO THE CITIZENS THAT
THE REVENUE M. WAS HAVING AN
IMPACT --
AND SECONDLY WE WANTED TO KIND
OF SPREAD TO THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
WORK AROUND OUR LOCAL --
AND CONSTRUCTION AGENCIES --
CONSTRUCTION TEMP FIRMS AND WE
KNEW THAT CALTRANS WITH
INVESTING A LOT IN SOME OF THE
LARGER PROJECTS SO.
A LOT OF OUR LARGER THAN FIRMS
WOULD HAVE A LOT OF WORK WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE WE WERE ABLE
TO START GROWING ARE.
AT AND SUPPORTING SOME OF THE
INDUSTRY THAT CAN WORK ON THE
SMALLER AND MEDIUM SIZE PROJECTS --
SO JUST AN EXAMPLE OF THE KIND
OF RANGE OF PROJECTS WE DID WITH
THIS FINDING THEM BECAUSE
SOMETIMES PAVEMENT
REHABILITATION DOESN'T SOUND
THAT EXCITING BUT IT IS ACTUALLY
VERY MEANINGFUL.
WE'RE ABLE TO RECONSTRUCT A
ROADWAY IN FRONT OF THEM GRANT
HIGH SCHOOL SO GRAND AVENUE --
IN ONE OF OUR SIR MAJOR URBAN
HIGH SCHOOLS AND THAT FORMERLY
HAD PCI OF THIRTY ANSWERABLE TO
RECONSTRUCT THAT.
AND YOU CAN IMAGINE THE
THOUSANDS OF US THROUGH ITS
GRAVEL BASICALLY.
IT WAS A VERY VERY POOR
CONDITION YET THIRTIES SEC
THAT'S REAL OPPORTUNITY --
OBVIOUSLY WE HAD THOUSANDS OF OF
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS THEM COMING
TO THAT EVERY DAY --
IN THE SOUTH AREA ON MACROS ME
MAY BE FAMILIAR WITH THAT WAS
ONE OF THOSE RADWAYS THAT WE
ARE CONSTANTLY FILLING POTHOLES
WE'RE ABLE TO OVERLAY THAT'S
THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE TO CONTINUE.
TO DO THE EMERGENCY REPAIRS AND
WE'RE ALSO ABLE TO BUILD IN SOME
BUFFERED BIKE LANES TO MAKE IT
SAFER FROM THE TRAVEL --
PROBABLY SOMETHING THAT --
IS PROBABLY MOST VISIBLE IS IN
OUR CENTRAL CITY WE HAVE ADOPTED
A PLAN TO BUILD.
A SYSTEM FOR SAFER AND MORE AND
PROTECT LOW STRESS NETWORK FOR
BICYCLING PEDESTRIANS TO MAKE IT
EASIER TO MOVE AROUND.
SO WITH THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
BEGIN THAT WITH OUR SB ONE FUNDS
DOING A PAYMENT MAINTENANCE AND
DEVELOPING A LOT OF OUR OUR
CLASS FOR PROTECTED BUFFERED
BIKE LANES SO.
OUR PARKING PROTECTED BY CLAIMS
WHICH YOU'LL SEE ON JAY STREET
INTENSE STREET WHERE THE BIKE
WEIGHS THE CYCLISTS ARE NOW
PROTECTED FROM MOVING TRAFFIC BY
THAT THE PARKING LANE.
AND WE ALSO GOT ADDITIONAL GRANT
FUNDING TO CONTINUE THAT PROGRAM.
AND FINALLY AND WHAT WE NORMALLY
DON'T FOCUS A LOT OF ARE
PREVENTIVE MAINTENANCE ON OUR
RESIDENTIAL NEIGHBORHOODS
BECAUSE AND THE CARD THAT THE
OTHER.
ROADWAYS TEND TO HAVE HIGHER THE
ARTERIAL COLLECTORS HAVE HIGHER
TRAFFIC VOLUMES.
AS I SAID WE'RE VERY OLD CITY WE
HAVE BEEN RETROFITTING A LOT OF
OUR OLDER NEIGHBORHOODS WITH
WATER ETERS WHICH REALLY AND
TORE UP THE PAVEMENT.
AND SO WE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GO AND AND REPAVE AFTER THE
WATER METER INSTALLATION. ONE OF
THE BENEFITS OF DOING THAT AND
OUR OLDER NEIGHBOR BUILT MANY
MANY YEARS AGO SO THIS IS A
CHANCE TO INCORPORATE ALL THOSE
ACCESSIBILITY IMPROVEMENT SO
THERE'S MOBILITY NOW ALL THE
CURB RAMPS ARE IN --
FOR I AM MORE OF OUR RESIDENTS
SO THAT'S ANOTHER PLUS.
SO -- THAT'S
WHAT WE DID THAT AND THAT'S KIND
OF A SNAPSHOT OF THE KINDS OF
PROJECTS THAT WE'RE DOING --
WE ALSO WERE PLEASED TO GET --
SOME OF THE GRANT PROGRAMS AM
SOME ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION AND
AND OTHER HIGH PRIORITY PROJECTS
THAT WE ARE.
WERE LOOKING FORWARD TO
DELIVERING NEXT YEAR --
AND ONE OF OUR ONE OF THE I
THINK THE TWO BLESSINGS WITH
THEM.
SB ONE IS IT NOW ALLOWS US TO
PLAN AHEAD AND LOOK FORWARD
BECAUSE WE HAVE AN ONGOING
SOURCE OF FINDING --
BOTH FOR OUR LONG TERM
PREVENTATIVE MAINTENANCE AND AS
WELL AS LOOKING AT OUR GRANT
PROGRAMS AND HOW WE CAN QUEUE
THINGS UP.
SO THAT AGAIN I WANNA.
THANK YOU IT REALLY HAS BEEN A
LIFESAVER FOR WHERE WE WERE A
COUPLE YEARS AGO --
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY.
OKAY THANK YOU WILL KERN TO MARC
WATTS FROM --
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA --
MARK.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE OF COMMISSIONERS ON
I'M SO USED TO GOING TO PUBLIC
AGENCIES.
OF THE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
PLEASED TO BE HERE MY NAME IS
MARK WHAT'S ON HERE WE HAVE A
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA TODAY
WHICH IS AN ORGANIZATION THAT
HAS.
HAD AS ITS CHARTER TRYING TO
ENSURE THE ADEQUATE FLOW
TRANSPORTATION REVENUES TO MEET
THE PUBLIC'S NEEDS.
I'M GONNA TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE ECONOMIC BENEFITS OF
SP ONE AS WE SEE HIM.
I WILL SAY AT THE OUTSET OF THIS
IS NOT BASED ON ANY NEW ANALYSIS
HAS BEEN DONE.
THE BASIS FOR THIS WAS DATA AND
CONCLUSIONS DRAWN A YEAR AGO AS
WE WERE IN THE THROES OF DEALING
WITH THE REPEAL INITIATIVE.
BUT NEVERTHELESS I THINK THE YOU
THE THE POINT THAT WAS MADE
EARLIER OVER HERE THAT THESE
COLLECTION OF THE REVENUES ONLY
STARTED A YEAR AND A QUARTER AGO
AND THE APPLICATION OF THOSE
REVENUES.
ON ON A FIRM BASE IS KNOWING
THAT IS THE PROP SIX FAILED.
HIS HIS IN FULL FLOW AND I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO TAKE A SECOND THANK.
ALL THE REPRESENTATIVES OF
CITIES AND COUNTIES STATE AND
REGIONAL AGENCIES FOR DOING A
MARVELOUS JOB THE COMMISSION DID
A GREAT JOB SETTING THINGS UP.
FOR YOU ALL CAME THROUGH WITH
THE PROJECTS AND ARE DELIVERING
I'M SO.
ON BEHALF OF THE INDUSTRY THAT I
REPRESENT TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
SO FIRST OFF --
THIS IS THE FIRST FULL YEAR OF
SB ONE BUDGETING RESOURCES WE'RE
IN THE MIDST OF THAT --
FIRST FISCAL YEAR OF WHERE WE
FOUND A YEAR AGO BEHEADING IN
INTO THIS --
INTO THE CYCLE WAS THAT.
THE SP ONE WAS SUPPORT ABOUT A
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN INCREASED ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY ACROSS THE BOARD.
THAT BENEFIT CALIFORNIA
RESIDENCES AND BEN AND
BUSINESSES.
AND OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS THAT
WOULD AVERAGE OUT OVER EIGHTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR --
AS THE LEVEL OF INVESTMENT
INCREASES DURING THAT PERIOD SB
ONE WILL SUPPORT.
AN ADDITIONAL SEVENTY OR SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND JOBS OR SEVENTY
THOUSAND PER YEAR OVER THAT
PERIOD OF TIME.
AND WE ARE STILL COLLECTING DATA
AND I THINK WE READING THE
REPORT THAT I ALLUDED TO SO WE
HAVE MORE --
ABILITY TO TRACK CLOSE MORE
CLOSELY WHAT.
WHAT THE BENEFITS HAVE BEEN?
SOME OF THE OTHER LONG RANGE OF
BENEFITS --
THE REPAIR REPAVING
RECONSTRUCTION OF OVER EIGHTY
FOUR THOUSAND LES MILES --
NINETEEN THOUSAND MILES OF ROAD
WAY AND A SEVEN THOUSAND NAY
MILES A RURAL INTERSTATES OVER
THE NEXT.
DECADE WHICH I FIND PROTECT
IMPORTANT SINCE I LIVE IN A
RURAL AREA.
THE USE THE FOCUS OF ATTENTION
THERE.
OF NEW DISHING DRIVERS WILL
SPEND LESS MONEY FIXING THEIR
CARS AND TRUCKS.
I'LL SAVE AN AVERAGE OF EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR
IN OPERATING COSTS OVER THAT
PERIOD --
HIT ANY IN ADDITION FIFTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR.
IN ADDITIONAL SAVINGS OF SIXTY
BENEFITS WERE FOUND.
BY OUR CONSULTANTS AS THEY
ANALYZE THIS AS CRASH INJURY
INFIDELITY WRITES A RATES WILL
DECLINE OVER THAT PERIOD --
I WAS GOING TO TALK BRIEFLY
ABOUT HOW WE KEY ESTIMATED THIS
I'M NOT GOING TO BOTHER WITH
THAT BECAUSE I THINK WE'VE ALL
LIVED THROUGH ECONOMIC.
ANALYSES IN THE PAST BUT TO
CONCLUDE --
AS MENTIONED BEFORE. SIX THIRTY
TWO JOB YEARS OVER A DECADE.
THERE WERE WORKERS THEMSELVES
WERE EARNED THIRTY THREE BILLION
DURING THAT PERIOD.
TECH GROSS STATE PRODUCT WILL BE
BILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR --
AND THE THE THAT I'VE MENTIONED
THE JOB.
RATINGS ONE LAST THING I WANT TO
KIND OF PERSONALIZED IS A TOUCH
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN USING OLD DATA --
I BY LOOK THROUGH AND SPOKE TO
SEVERAL OF THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE PART PART OF OUR PART
OF OUR COALITION.
AND FIRST OFF --
THERE ARE PRESSURES ON THE
INDUSTRY THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY AND OUR LABOR ALLIES TO
GET PEOPLE PREPARED AND INTO THE
JOBS.
I KNOW --
SENATOR REQUIRE WAS INCLUDING TO
HOW DO WE FOCUS AT ON THE STATE.
THIS INFORMATION IS AREAS IS
PRETTY MUCH MORE GENERICALLY
BROADLY --
BROADCAST TO NOT FOCUS ON STATE
VERSUS PRIVATE SECTOR.
BUT THE EMPLOYMENT FOR
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS IS IS
EXPECTED TO CONTINUE TO GROW
FASTER THAN ANY OTHER INDUSTRY.
AND THAT'S THE BUREAU OF LABOR
STATISTICS AND THEY THINK.
HIM CONSTRUCTION EQUIPMENT
OPERATORS FOR EXAMPLE.
THE RATE OF GROWTH WILL BE --
WELL OVER 12% BY.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY SIX SO IT'S
PRETTY HEALTHY INDUSTRY.
MEDIUM ATTACK MAKIN FROM.
GOING TO COLLEGE AND GET THANK.
OTHER EVIDENCE OF OF HOW THIS IS
TRANSLATING IS OPERATING
ENGINEERS.
HAVE.
AN APPRENTICESHIP
APPRENTICESHIPS CENTER.
THAT'S GROWING BY LEAPS AND
BOUNDS EACH YEAR.
OF LABOR'S HAS THEIR PROGRAM
GROWING AS WELL AND THE
CARPENTERS HAVE A NEW TRAINING
FACILITY COMING ONLINE OR
STARTING CONSTRUCTION I'M.
SORRY --
THIS MONTH IN PLEASANTON SO WE
CAN SEE THAT THE EFFORT TO
PROVIDE SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE.
IS IN MOTION AND I THINK IT
SHOULD HAVE SOME --
OF MATERIAL AFFECTS HOW WELL YOU
NEED TO DO FOR THE STATE.
AND WITHOUT DRAW THAT TO A CLOSE.
THANK YOU --
JUST A COUPLE QUESTIONS I THINK
FOR THE PANELISTS IN GENERAL --
IN TERMS OF MEASUREMENT OF THE
ROAD CONDITIONS AND KIND OF LIKE
TO GIVE IT GIVE US A PERSPECTIVE
[inaudible]
OF WHAT WE NEED VERSES WHERE WE
ARE WITH SP.
ONE YOU KNOW WE WERE IN REALLY
BAD SHAPE RUNNING RUNNING KIND
OF GIVE US THE WHERE ARE WERE
LITERALLY AT IT'S OF A WATERFALL
OF DESTRUCTION I THINK YEAH.
AT AVERAGE OF FIFTY FIVE IN
TERMS OF ROAD CONDITION
[inaudible]
LEVELS --
THE AND THEN YOU'RE YOU'RE
SAYING WE'RE GOING TO HIT WE'RE
GONNA STATE [inaudible]
SIXTY FIVE WE'RE WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GET BETTER SIXTY FIVE US OKAY
BUT IT'S FAIR NOT NOT GOOD.
CORRECT.
SO -- WHAT
IS THE UNFUNDED NEEDS AND?
IS THERE --
IS THERE ANY IDEAS OF DEALING
WITH THAT ANYWHERE.
THAT'S A QUESTION I HAVE.
MANA DE YEAH I CAN HEAR YOU --
I THINK HE SAID THE GENERAL FUND
OF THE CITY OF SAN LEANDRO.
THAT MIGHT NOT BE AVAILABLE FOR
EVERY CITY ME.
SO GO AHEAD RUNNING SURE SO IN
THOSE WITH THE LATEST --
LOCAL SHE TO ROAD THESE SAYS MAY
FROM --
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE LOOKED AT
WHAT THE YOUNG FUNDED --
UNMET FUNDING NEEDS WOULD BE
WILL BE OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS
WITH SB.
ONE AND AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
IN MY TESTIMONY --
IT CONSISTENTLY EXCEED OVER
SEVENTY BILLION BUT THANKS SB --
ONE THAT ON ON MATH FUNDING NEED
IS NOW.
ON METHADONE FUNDING NEED --
AND I THINK THE REAL TAKE AWAY
THERE IS THAT TWO THIRDS OF THE
NETWORK WILL ACTUALLY MOVE INTO
GOOD CONDITION.
BECAUSE OF THE FIX IT FOR
STRATEGY RIGHT AND SO YOU'RE
LOOKING AT KIND OF GETTING THE
BEST BANG FOR YOUR BUCK --
SO THAT YOU'RE NOT JUST
RECONSTRUCTING YOU WROTE ALL
OVER THE PLACE BUT YOU'RE REALLY
FOCUSING IN ON WHERE YOU CAN
MAXIMIZE THOSE DOLLARS AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S WHY WE SEE.
A GOOD A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER A
PERCENTAGE OF THAT NETWORK
MOVING TO SET A GOOD REPAIR --
BUT THE IMF FUNDING NEEDS WILL
STILL -- BE
PRETTY LARGE AND I THINK --
MISTER COOK FROM SAN LEANDRO --
ALLUDED TO THIS EARLIER THAT A
FEDERAL FUNDING HAS BEEN.
HAS CONSISTENTLY KIND OF SHRUNK
OVER THE YEARS IN TERMS OF HOW
CITIES AND COUNTIES BENEFIT FROM --
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
TRANSPORTATION.
YOU KNOW THAT THERE ARE A COUPLE
THINGS I DID WANT TO MENTION --
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE'VE ALREADY
DONE WITH THE FUNDING IF I IF I
MAY.
UM IN ACCORDING TO THE CDC'S
REPORT --
FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN CITIES
AND COUNTIES --
WERE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE THEIR
SB ONE SHARE --
THE SOME OF THE PROJECT LISTEN
THEREFORE BECAME ELIGIBLE --
BECAUSE THE FIRST FISCAL YEAR
WAS ONLY A PARTIAL YEAR WORTH
WORTH OF FINDING --
SOME SORT OF THE ONE AND A HALF
BILLION THAT WE HEAR ABOUT THE
RIGHT GOING IT ANNUALLY TO
CITIES AND COUNTIES IS ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX MILLION
THAT WENT OUT.
IN THAT PARTIAL FISCAL YEAR THE
FOR THE VERY FIRST YEAR OF OF SB --
ONE OF THAT THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
SIX MILLION A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SIX MILLION WAS ACTUALLY SPENT --
ON PROJECTS --
BY CITIES AND COUNTIES --
AND SO THERE WERE ACTUALLY OVER
THOU FIRST ROUND OF FIT AND IN
THAT FIRST FISCAL YEAR --
AND ANOTHER SEVENTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS --
WAS SPENT ON IN PROGRESS --
PROJECTS AND SO I JUST WANT TO
THROW THAT OUT THERE SO THAT --
JUST TO KIND OF HIGHLIGHT THE
FACT THAT EVEN THOUGH THE MONEY
IS JUST BARELY STARTED TRICKLING
IN -- THERE
WAS SO MUCH WORK THAT NEEDED TO
GO AROUND THAT CITIES AND
COUNTIES STARTED SPENDING IT.
RIGHT AWAY THAT'S THAT'S HOW
MUCH WORK --
WAS NECESSARY SO --
THE MONEY IS GOING OUT AND IT'S
GOING OUT QUICKLY AND WE'RE
LOOKING FOR TO SEE TO SEEING HOW
MUCH MONEY GETS SPENT IN THIS.
FULL FISCAL YEARS WORTH OF FUNNY
BECAUSE IT'S ONE AND A HALF
MILLION VERSUS THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY SIX MILLION SO --
ABOUT FIVE TIMES LARGER RIGHT --
AND SO TO BE INTERESTING TO SEE
THOSE DOLLARS GO.
THEY ARE COMMENTS ON THE THE
BILL OF WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
PREPARING. TO ENTER DEUCE OF A
RESOLUTE A JOINT RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
ASSN CONGRESS. TO DO THEIR SHARE
NOW.
AND THE PRESIDENT TO THEIR THEIR
SURE FOR A NATIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING.
BILL.
OF TO PICK UP THE SLACK WHEN WAS
THE LAST TIME THE CONGRESS.
AND FROM GOVERNMENT INCREASED
FUNDING.
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
TRANSPORTATION AS A LIKE. TWENTY
FIVE YEARS ME.
MARK DO YOU REMEMBER A LONG.
TIME JAMES SAID KAREN RECALLED
SO BEFORE WE DO DECADES YEAH.
BEFORE GOVERNOR DEUKMEJIAN.
INCREASE IT WAS BEFORE GOVERNOR
DEUKMEJIAN INCREASE THE GAS TAX
PRIOR TO SB ONE CORRECT.
MEANWHILE AROUND AND I KNOW THAT
AS I WAS THERE WITH.
PRESIDENT REAGAN ACTUALLY --
OF OVERSAW THE INCREASE OF A
NICKEL --
INCREASE IN THE EIGHTIES
EIGHTEEN CENTS AND WANTED TO
EIGHT THE FEDERAL GAS TAXES
EIGHTEEN SENSE.
AND IT'S BEEN THERE.
FOR A LONG TIME.
AND THEY HAVE AN INCREASED IT
BUT THEY HAVE --
THERE HAVEN'T FUNDED THROUGH
OTHER SEEING --
OTHER FUNDING.
AT ALL FOR TRANSPORTATION FROM
TIME TO TIME DURING VARIOUS OF
THE EXTENSIONS THEY HAVE PUT --
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS GENERAL FUND
INTO THE INTO THE MIX ARE FUN.
NOT ON A SUSTAIN ONGOING BASIS.
AND NOT AS A PACK FEEL.
LIKE WE NEED TO LOOK AT THAT AND
FIND OUT WHAT CONGRESS IS DOING
IF THEY COULD THROW SOME MORE
MONEY.
AND I THINK RIGHT NOW WITH THE
SPECIALLY SINCE YOU'RE SAYING.
SB ONE HELPED.
RELIEVE THE DEFICIT IN ROAD
MAINTENANCE BUT IT DIDN'T
COMPLETE FUNDING.
AND ROAD MAINTENANCE IN THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE DOING HALF
CENT SALES TAX THEY'RE DOING.
GENERAL FUND ON OTHER KINDS OF
WAYS OF FUNDING --
THE GAP IF THEY CAN IF THEY CAN
WITH.
IS NOT GONNA BE ENOUGH ON A
SUSTAINABLE BASIS.
KERR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING --
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT --
DO YOU ALL AGREE THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE.
OF MORAL BUSTS --
JOB CREATION WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT.
FOR CONSTRUCTION --
ANYBODY.
I BE HAPPY TO WAY AND I THINK A
LISTEN TO THE PREVIOUS PANEL ON
THE QUESTIONS FROM THE SENATOR
ABOUT WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT I
THINK IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL AND
WHAT MISTER WHAT SAID.
MS I MENTIONED EARLIER IS A
MULTI MODAL TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY WE SEE ACROSS ALL ASPECTS
WHETHER IT'S COACH OPERATORS
MECHANICS.
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS
PROFESSIONALS IN OTHER PARTS AS
WELL AS OPPORTUNITY NEARS IN THE
ABILITY TO DO OUR CONSTRUCTION
ACTIVITIES WE SEE THAT AS A REAL
RISK AND I WOULD SAY THAT.
THAT RISK EVEN GOES UP IN HIGH
COST OF LIVING COASTAL AREAS --
AS WE WOULD PUT HERSELF INTO
THAT.
SO WE'VE BEEN --
ACTIVE IN THAT SUPPORTING
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
APPROPRIATE WE PARTICIPATE A
GROUP CALLED ABILITY TWENTY ONE
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
A PUBLIC PRIVATE --
GROUP AND THAT ALSO HAS A
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
VERY SPECIFICALLY FOCUSING ON
OUT MISTER WATCHES INDICATED SO
I I WOULD.
SAY IT'S A VERY REAL CONCERN AND
I THINK IT SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON
AT THE STATE LEVEL AS WELL AS
UNDERSTANDING THE SUB REGIONAL
CONTEXT IN WHICH WE WE OPERATE
IN THE US OKAY SUB REGIONAL ALSO
NOW.
GABRIEL SOME COMMENTS WILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE WILL GO AROUND OUR
LAST PANEL WE HAVE --
SIR REVENUE FUTURE.
WE HAVE --
DOCTOR -- A
SHRUG ORDER WALL FROM SAN JOSE
STATE MINETA TRANSPORTATION
INSTITUTE.
AND ALLEN JUNE FROM UC DAVIS
INSTITUTE FOR TRANSPORTATION
STUDIES --
WILL HAVE THOSE TWO INDIVIDUALS
COME FOR PLEASE AND WELCOME
[inaudible]
OKAY.
AND I THINK.
DOCTOR A AGO WHILE YOUR FIRST
AND BELIEVE.
ARE YOU DONE [inaudible]
STE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
YEAR BEFORE.
HEY WHAT ARE.
YEAH THERE OF A TRY AGAIN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE INVITATION
TO SPEAK TODAY AT THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
I AM HERE REPRESENTING THE
MINETA TRANSPORTATION INSTITUTE
AND RESEARCH THAT I IN SOME OF
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE DONE THROUGH
THAT INSTITUTE WHICH IS OF
COURSE -- ON
THE TOPIC OF TODAY LOOKING AT
THE FUTURE OF TRANSPORTATION
REVENUES FOR THE STATE.
AND WHAT I'M GOING TO DO WITH
HIS SHORT HAND OUT I'VE SHARED
IS JUST I'VE EXTRACTED A FEW OF
THE KEY IDEAS FROM TO A COUPLE
OF DIFFERENT PIECES OF RESEARCH
THAT WE'RE DOING THAT I THINK
WILL INFORM.
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF WHERE ARE
WE GOING ON IF WE MORE OR LESS
CONTINUED COLLECTING STATE LEVEL
REVENUES AND FEES THE WAY WE'RE
CURRENTLY DOING.
WHERE WOULD BEAT ME IN TWENTY
TWENTY OR TO THE FIRST PROJECT
I'D LIKE TO TO BRIEFLY GIVE YOU
A FEW HIGHLIGHTS FROM --
WAS DONE WITH CO AUTHORS MARTIN
WAX AND HANNA KING AND WE WERE
TASKED ON JUST WITH VERY
DIRECTLY.
HOW MUCH REVENUE WILL THE STATE?
BRING IN EACH YEAR THROUGH
TWENTY FORTY LOOKING AGAIN AND
THIS IS IMPORTANT ONLY AT STATE
COLLECTED FEES SO.
LOCAL THINGS ARE NOT ON THE
TABLE FEDERAL MONEY IS NOT ON
THE TABLE.
AND ALSO STATE REVENUE SOURCES
THAT ARE SPECIFICALLY DEDICATED
TO TRANSPORTATION SO SOMETHING
LIKE THE VEHICLE LICENSE FEE
THOSE REVENUES EVEN THOUGH IT
SOUNDS LIKE A TRANSPORTATION TAX
AND SHE ARTS SPENT.
BY STATUTE DIRECTLY ON
TRANSPORTATION SO WE'RE NOT
LOOKING AT THOSE --
SO WE ARE LOOKING AT ARE ON
EXCISE TAXES ON GAS AND DIESEL --
AND ALSO THE SORT OF INCREMENTAL
NEW REGISTRATION FEE THE THE
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENT FEE
WHICH SB ONE PUT ON TO VEHICLE
REGISTRATIONS AND ALSO A ROAD
IMPROVEMENT FEE.
ASSESSED ON NINE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES.
SO THE FIRST ARM OF THE TABLES --
THE THE GRAPHICS YOU'LL SEE.
IS JUST LOOKING AT THESE
DIFFERENT REVENUE SOURCES OUT
THROUGH TWENTY FORTY AND THE
COLORED BANDS REPRESENT THE FACT
THAT.
ANY PROJECTION IS A GAS AND SO
WE'VE TAKE SCENARIOS IN TERMS OF
POPULATION GROWTH --
INFLATION AND OTHER KEY FACTORS
SO YOU CAN SEE THIS SORT OF
CLOUD OF POSSIBILITIES DEPENDING
ON A A RANGE OF LIKELY FUTURES.
AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE THESE
COLORED BANDS NOT JUST A LINE AT
ANY RATE YOU WILL SEE THAT OUT
THROUGH TWENTY FOUR FORTY THE
GASOLINE TAX IS STILL BY FAR THE
BIGGEST CHUNK OF MONEY.
ON AND IF YOU ADD EVERYTHING UP
BY TWENTY FORTY I BELIEVE IT'LL
BE SOMETHING ROUGHLY AROUND
EIGHT NINE BILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR IF YOU COMBINE ALL OF THIS.
ON IF YOU LOOK AT THE THE BAR
GRAPH JUST BELOW THAT AGAIN
SHOWS YOU THAT THE RELATIVE
PROPORTION.
OF NO IF IF EACH YEAR IS A 100%
OF THE MONEY THE STATE'S
BRINGING IN FOR TRANSPORTATION
WHAT PROPORTION OF THAT.
IS COMING FROM SAY THE ROAD
IMPROVEMENT FEE ON ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES OR GASOLINE EXCISE TAX
IN AGAIN IS MAKES QUITE CLEAR
THAT.
MANY PEOPLE HAVE TOLD US THE
GASOLINE TAXES ON ITS WAY OUR
ROAD AND IT'S NO LONGER WORKABLE.
AND I'M NOT HERE TO SAY WHETHER
WE SHOULD CHANGE IT OR NOT TODAY
BUT I WOULD JUST OINT OUT THAT
IT WILL STILL REYES QUITE A BIT
OF REVENUE.
INTO THE FUTURE EVEN IF WE
DIDN'T CHANGE ANYTHING UNDER
LIKELY SCENARIOS.
NOW THE NEXT THING IF YOU TURN
TO THE FOLLOWING PAGE THERE'S
THIS THIS FIGURE THAT SAYS DRAFT
ALL OVER IT BECAUSE THIS IS AN
ADDITIONAL PRODUCT THAT MY CO
AUTHORS AND I HAVE BEEN WORKING
ON IN RESPONSE TO A VERY
SENSIBLE QUESTION I THOUGHT FROM --
FRAN IN MEN CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATIONCOMMISSIONER WHO
ASKED WELL WHAT ABOUT IF WE HAVE
A MUCH FASTER PENETRATE.
ON HOW WOULD THAT CHANGE THE
PRODUCTIONS LOOKING OUT INTO THE
FUTURE.
SO WHAT WE ARE DOING HERE IS
WE'RE JUST ESTIMATING OVERALL
REVENUES WITH SORT OF IF EVEY
SALES JUST CONTINUED AT EXACTLY
THE RATE THEY'RE CURRENTLY GOING.
THAT'S OUR LOW EVEY SCENARIO AND
THEN OUR HIGH EVEY SCENARIO
LOOKS AT IF WE'D MET THE STATE'S
CURRENT TARGETS --
WHICH MEAN BY TWENTY FORTY WOULD
HAVE ROUGHLY 25% OF OUR FLEET
WOULD BE ELECTRIC.
ON THIS OF THOSE OF THOSE TO
THOSE SORT OF BLUE AND THE
YELLOW LINES THE YELLOW CAN IS
THE THE LOW EVEY PENETRATIONS SO.
MORE OF OUR CARS ARE STILL
RUNNING ON GASOLINE WERE
COLLECTING THOSE GAS TAXES FROM
THEM AND DIESEL.
I'M TO ME STRIKING IS THAT
THERE'S NOT ACTUALLY THAT BIG A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THOSE TWO
LINES -- I
MEAN THERE IS A DIFFERENCE
ROUGHLY ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
HARDLY CHANGE THAT WILL SNEEZE
AT BUT I THINK SOMETIMES THERE'S
AN A A CONCERN THAT.
WE KNOW IF WE WE IF WE DON'T GET
RID OF THE GAS TAX --
IF.
IF THE CHANGE IN.
A TRACE OF ELECTRIC VEHICLES IS
GREAT SUDDENLY WE'RE JUST HOW
THE FLEET THAT'S ENTIRELY
ELECTRIC IN THERE REALLY WON'T
BE REVENUE COMING IN FROM THE
GASOLINE TAX.
AND ARE ARE THESE DRAFT
PROJECTIONS SO THAT NO THERE
WOULD STILL BE A QUITE A LOT OF
REVENUE COMING IN THROUGH GAS
AND DIESEL TAXES --
ALTHOUGH CERTAINLY SOMEWHAT LESS
THAN IF IF WE HAD FEWER EASY'S
ON THE ROAD.
SO THIS IS THE WORK THAT WE HAVE
DONE ON PROJECTIONS AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS EITHER
HERE OR GO BACK AND DO SOME
ADDITIONAL FOLLOW UP IF NEEDED.
THE LAST THING I WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT S A PART TO THIS IS
PUBLIC OPINION ON GAS AND GAS
TAXES IN MILEAGE FEES.
AND SO --
ANOTHER --
WHICH I'VE DONE IN COLLABORATION
WITH DR HILLARY NIXON IS NOW A
NINE YEAR ANNUAL SERIES OF POOLS
WHERE WE ASK US ADULTS SO IT'S
NOT JUST CALIFORNIA BUT ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
WHETHER THEY WOULD SUPPORT
DIFFERENT VARIATIONS ON
INCREASING THE FEDERAL GAS TAX
RATE -- AND
WE ALSO HAVE A COUPLE OF
HYPOTHETICAL QUESTIONS ABOUT IT
A MILEAGE FEE.
SO AGAIN THESE ARE RANDOM
SURVEYS OF ADULTS IN THE US. TO
TWELVE HUNDRED OR MORE
RESPONDENTS EACH YEAR AND WE'VE
KEPT THE QUESTIONNAIRE IS
VIRTUALLY IDENTICAL FROM YEAR TO
YEAR SO THAT WE COULD
EFFECTIVELY LOOK AT TRENDS.
AND SO IF YOU TURN TO THE LAST
GRAPHIC ON THE FINAL PAGE WHAT
WE HAVE HERE.
OUR PEOPLE'S SUPPORT FOR A
VARIETY OF OF DIFFERENT WAYS WE
COULD INCREASE THE FEDERAL GAS
TAX IN ALL CASE IT WOULD BE. TEN
CENTS HIGHER SO THAT'S THE SAME
BUT AT THE BOTTOM WE HAVE OUR
BASE LINE WHICH IS WHERE WE JUST
TOLD PEOPLE. 2010% TEN CENT PER
GALLON INCREASE FOR
TRANSPORTATION.
AND WE DIDN'T GIVE THEM ANY
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
IN ALL OF THE OTHERS IN THE LOSE
OF MOVING UP THE TABLE WE GAVE
VARIATIONS SO AT THE VERY TOP WE
SAID WELL WHAT IF WE INCREASE
THE FEDERAL GAS TAX BY TEN CENT
PER GALLON.
BUT WE DEDICATED THE MONEY TO
MAINTAINING ROADS AND HIGHWAYS.
ON AND YOU WILL NOTICE THAT WE
HAVE MUCH MUCH REALLY ALMOST
DOUBLE THE SUPPORT FOR THAT SAME
TEN CENT PER GALLON INCREASE IN
THE GAS TAX.
IF THE MONEY WERE DEDICATED FOR
MAINTENANCE AND SO THAT'S THAT'S
ONE OF THE KEY TAKE AWAYS FROM
ME IF THIS PUBLIC POLLING IS.
BUT I THINK THE PUBLIC A RATHER
SENSIBLE THEY DON'T JUST ACROSS
THE BOARD REJECT.
ANY POSSIBLE TRANSPORTATION TAX
THEY THINK ABOUT IT --
YOU KNOW IS IT SOMETHING THAT'S
ACTUALLY GOING TO HELP ACHIEVE
PRIORITIES THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO
ME -- AND I
HAVE MANY OTHER THINGS OF COURSE --
AND SO THE THE SORT OF KEY THE
MOST POPULAR VARIANTS OF THESE
GAS TAX INCREASES IT WE ASKED
ABOUT WHERE THE MAINTENANCE --
ONE I JUST MENTIONED ALSO A TAX
WITH REVENUE WOULD BE DEDICATED
FOR SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS ON AGAIN
BASICALLY SUPERMAJORITY SUPPORT.
AND AND SOME OTHER VARIANTS IT
LOOKED AT FOR EXAMPLE PROJECTS --
TO MONEY TO BE SPENT ON PROJECTS
THAT WOULD REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS OR AIR POLLUTANTS ALSO
QUITE POPULAR WITH MAJORITY
SUPPORT.
SO THAT'S AGAIN ONE OF MY KEY
TAKE AWAYS IS THIS FACT THAT
PEOPLE DON'T TREAT ALL TAXES THE
SAME THEY THINK ABOUT IT IN SOME
THEY WILL SOME EVERYBODY HATES
MORE LESS THAN OTHERS.
QUITE A MAJORITY OF THE PUBLIC
ACTUALLY COULD SUPPORT.
THE LAST FINDING I'LL POINT OUT
IS THAT WHAT WE'RE SHOWING YOU
HERE IN THIS CASE IS THE RESULTS
FROM ASKING THESE IDENTICAL
SURVEY QUESTIONS OVER A NUMBER
OF YEARS.
AND THE THE SORT OF IT IN THE
BOTTOM OF EACH SECTION THE THE
WHITISH COLOR BAR THAT'S GOING
BACK TO TWENTY TEN AND THEN
SERVE AS YOU MARCH UP WE'RE
GETTING CLOSER TO THE FUTURE.
AND IN PRETTY MUCH EVERY CASE
FOR EVERYONE OF THESE TAX
VARIANTS SUPPORT HAS INCREASED
SINCE.
TWENTY TEN AND YOU KNOW VERY
ROUGHLY IT'S BEEN JUST INCREASE
WITH SOME HICK UPS HERE AND
THERE BUT IT SEEMS TO BE QUITE A
STEADY PATTERN ACROSS ALL OF THE
TAXES -- AND
WE WE DON'T HAVE OUR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN DATA SHOWING HERE BUT
IT WAS WOULD HAVE TOO MUCH OF A
BOB UP BUMP UP BUT IT WAS THE
SAME GENERAL PATTERN NOW I CAN'T
TELL YOU OR HITTING A PEAK AND
THINGS WILL CHANGE --
NEXT YEAR BUT CERTAINLY OVER THE
LAST YEAR'S THERE SEEMS TO JUST
BE THIS GRADUAL.
MORE AND MORE OF THE POPULATION
ACCEPTING THAT THEY WOULD VALUE
IMPROVING OUR TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM EVEN IF THAT MEANS
SPENDING MORE.
SO THOSE REMARKS I HAD PREPARED
AND ANY QUESTIONS I'LL WAIT
UNTIL OF THE NEXT BAKER AND WILL
ASK US QUESTIONS OF THE PEOPLE
OF KOSOVO TURN OVER TO THE LAST
SPEAKER FOR TODAY.
HALOGEN IS --
HE'S A RESEARCH SCIENTIST FROM
UC DAVIS.
AND WELCOME.
THANK YOU --
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING ME TODAY --
PART OF SB --
ONE HAD A INCREASE IN --
OR INTRODUCTION OF A NEW ANNUAL
REGISTRATION FEE FOUR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES --
AND SO SB ONE PASSED --
UC DAVIS --
WITH STUDYING THE EFFECTS OF
THIS PARTICULAR FEE AND POSSIBLE
OCT ALTERNATIVE FUNDING
MECHANISMS --
AND SO I WAS THE PRINCIPAL
INVESTIGATOR FOR THE FOR THIS
PROJECT WHICH STUDY WHICH WHICH
YOU HAVEN'T IN FRONT OF YOU AND
PRE FOR VERSION OF THAT AS A AS
A POLICY BRIEF COM WHICH IS ALSO
PROVIDED THANK YOU --
ONE OF THE ONE OF THE KEY
ASPECTS --
AND DRAWBACKS THAT THAT WE
ACTUALLY FOUND WITH WITH THE
REGISTRATION FEE --
IS THAT --
WITH GASOLINE VEHICLE --
THE THE WAY THAT YOU CONTRIBUTE
TO FUNDING ROAD INFRASTRUCTURE
IS IS THROUGH THE GAS TAX AND SO
THE MORE THAT YOU DRIVE --
THE MORE THAT YOU PAY --
AND WITH THOSE THAT HAVE ANNUAL
REGISTRATION FEE THIS DEPARTS
FROM THE USER PAYS PRINCIPLE
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU
DRIVE A THOUSAND MILES A YEAR OR
TEN THOUSAND MILES A YEAR --
YOU'RE NOW PAYING THE SAME
AMOUNT --
AND SO FROM --
EQUITY STANDPOINT --
THERE ARE SOME ISSUES THERE.
THE SECOND DRAWBACK --
THAT THAT WE USE HAD IDENTIFIED --
WHICH WAS --
BROUGHT UP A BIT AND LOOK IN THE
LAST TESTIMONY WHAT CREATION FEE
ITSELF IS IS NOT ENTIRELY
SUSTAINABLE SO THE AVERAGE
VEHICLE IN CALIFORNIA PAYS ABOUT
A HUNDRED EIGHTY DOLLARS A YEAR --
AND THE ANNUAL REGISTRATION FEE
IS ABOUT HALF THAT SAYS YOU
TRANSITION MORE AND MORE TO
ELECTRIC VEHICLES YOU ARE SORT
OF DECREASING --
THE REVENUE BEING PROVIDED FOR
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE --
AND AND WE DO HAVE SIMILAR
FINDINGS TO TO WHAT PROFESSOR I
ROLL WAS STATING BY TWENTY
THIRTY IF WE ME CALIFORNIA'S --
FIVE MILLION --
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES ON THE
ROAD --
THAT'S GOING TO LEAD TO ABOUT A
HALF A BILLION DOLLARS IN IN
SHORTFALL IN REVENUE --
COMPARED TO WHAT IT WOULD BE
THAT THEY HAVE THERE BEEN
GASOLINE VEHICLES.
OUR IN TERMS OF THE ALTERNATIVE
MECHANISMS --
WE IDENTIFIED --
AND STUDIED TO IN PARTICULAR SO
ONE IS A FUEL TAX THAT WOULD BE
SIMILAR IN OPERATION TO A
GASOLINE TAX AND SO --
FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLES YOU WOULD
CHARGE A SPECIAL TAX FOR
LECTURES THE IN FOR HYDROGEN THE
SPECIAL TAX REDUCTION --
UNFORTUNATELY YOU KNOW IT IN
TERMS OF IMPLEMENTATION THIS CAN
BE A VERY DIFFICULT TASK --
PARTICULARLY FOR ELECTRICITY --
WHEN WHEN YOU PLUG IN ELECTRIC
THE?
IN ORDER TO HAVE THIS A SPECIFIC
TAX FOR THE VEHICLE YOU HAVE TO
TRACK THE ELECTRICITY GOING IN --
AND AND YOU'RE MEASURING THAT
COMPARED TO YOU HAVING
ELECTRICITY GOING TO LIGHTS OR
OTHER APPLIANCES IS VERY
DIFFICULT YOU NEED A SEPARATE
METER AND AND THAT IS ALMOST A
NON STARTER FOR PROGRAM LIKE
THAT BECAUSE IT WOULD BE.
WAY TOO EXPENSIVE TO IMPLEMENT A
SEPARATE METERING FOR FOR ALL
VEHICLES --
THE OTHER --
FEEDBACK IN THIS IN WHICH WE
EXAMINE WAS THAT ROAD USER
CHARGE OR A OR OR MILEAGE FEE
WHICH IS WHERE YOU PAY BY THE
MILE AND AND THIS IS ACTUALLY
SOMETHING THAT --
CALIFORNIA AND AND CALTRANS HAS
BEEN INVESTIGATING --
PARTICULARLY THROUGH --
SB TEN SEVENTY SEVEN WHICH WAS --
A PILOT FOR THAT FOR THE ROAD
USER CHARGING AND HAS NOW
CONCLUDED --
IN IN WORKING WITH CALTRANS AND
AND THE CDC WE ACTUALLY
DISCOVERED A A SORT OF UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY THROUGH ELECTRIC
VEHICLES FOR IMPLEMENTATION --
OF OF A ROCK --
AND THERE ARE SEVERAL SORT OF
BENEFITS THAT COME FROM FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLES --
SO FIRST THAT THE TECHNOLOGY
INTERMISSION VEHICLES IS IS A
LOT NEWER AND WE CAN LEVERAGE
SOME THE TELEMATICS SYSTEMS ON
BOARD THESE VEHICLES --
TO TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
MECHANISM --
OF A ROCK --
AND THAT WILL HELP SOLVE SOME OF
THE ASSOCIATE COST
ADMINISTRATION --
FOR HARDWARE THAT THAT THAT ARE
USUALLY ASSOCIATED WITH ROCKS
AND USUALLY THEY USE THAT THESE
ON BOARD EXTERNAL DEVICES --
THAT PLUG INTO THE OBD.
IN IN THE VEHICLE.
AND THAT CAN BE ENTIRELY AVOIDED --
SECONDLY IN IN A LOT OF THE
PROGRAMS FOR ROCKS THAT EXIST
TODAY MAINLY PILOT PROGRAMS YOU
HAVE THIS ISSUE WHERE VEHICLES
ARE VOLUNTEERING FOR THESE
PROGRAMS PARTICIPATING IN A ROCK --
WHERE THEY PAY BY THE MILE BUT
THEN ANY TIME THEY GET TO A GAS
STATION THEY'RE ALSO PAYING A
GAS TAX WHICH MEANS THEY HAVE TO
GET CREDITED BACK --
THE MONEY BECAUSE OF THE DOUBLE
PAYMENT WITH THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLES --
YOU TO AVOID THIS ISSUE ENTIRELY
THIS IS THAT WITH WITH THE VISA
AND ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
BECAUSE THE VOLUMES ARE SO MUCH
LOWER THAN THAT SORT OF GENERAL
POPULATION OF VEHICLES THE
TRANSITION TOWARDS THESE --
TOWARDS A ROCK SYSTEM FOR THIS
PARTICULAR SUBSET OF VEHICLES
WOULD BE MUCH SMALLER AND AND
EASIER TO IMPLEMENT.
AND THEN LASTLY --
IN IN TERMS OF SORT OF LONGER
TERM GOALS --
IF THERE IS A SYSTEM THAT IN
THAT IS ABLE TO COUPLE THE
TELEMATICS --
AND AND IN AN INTEGRATED WAY --
THAT ACTUALLY ENABLES POTENTIAL
FUTURE PRICING MECHANISMS AND SO
IN THE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
WE THINK ABOUT THINGS LIKE
CONGESTION PRICING --
OCCUPANCY PRICING --
AND YOU KNOW IT IN EACH OF THE
SYSTEMS.
IMPLEMENTATION IS ALWAYS A
CHALLENGE --
AND HAVING EVERYTHING IN IN AN
INNER INTEGRATED WAY MAY PROVE
TO BE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
ALLOWS FOR THESE --
PRICING MECHANISMS THAT HAPPEN
IN THE FUTURE --
AND SO -- IN
SUMMARY IN THE REPORT AND WE
PROVIDE SOME QUALITATIVE
ANALYSIS ABOUT.
THE RELATIVE STRENGTH AND
BENEFITS OF THE OF THE DIFFERENT --
PRICING MECHANISMS AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO THE ANNUAL
REGISTRATION FEE --
YEAH AND AND THAT CONCLUDES MY
MY TESTIMONY AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS --
JUST A COUPLE QUESTIONS FOR THE
ACADEMICS --
WHEN WE DID WHEN WE DID SB --
ONE WE STARTED --
THE CONCEPT OF DOING THE
RESEARCH TO AID.
THE DELIVERY OF SP ONE AND HOW
WE WERE.
THE CUSTOMER DOING RESEARCH WAS
MORE APPLYING IT TO CALIFORNIA.
TO TO THE WISE CHOICES THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE IN THE FUTURE.
AND HAVING SOME BACKGROUND ON
OUR OUR BILL EVER ARE IN DE ON
OUR DECISION MAKING PROCESS --
JUST -- THIS
IS VERY IMPORTANT WHAT YOU'RE
TELLING US RIGHT NOW SO WE DON'T
KNOW.
HOW DO WE DO THAT ON --
WHAT WHAT KIND OF MEANS YOU
THINK WE SHOULD DO?
ON A CONSISTENT ON GOING --
IS THAT YOU GIVE US REPORTS AND
STUFF OF HOW HOW WOULD YOU LOOK
AT COMMUNICATING WITH POLICY
MAKERS LIKE MYSELF AND AND MY MY
COLLEAGUES.
IN THE FUTURE ON HOW TO MAKE THE
RIGHT CHOICES ON SOME OF THESE
ISSUES HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON THAT
[inaudible]
YOUR YEAH --
SO.
SB ONE PROVIDES A A LARGE
PROPORTION OF FUNDING NOW FOR
FOR SOME OF THIS RESEARCH AND I
THINK OPEN LINES OF
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN THE POLICY
MAKERS AND AND THE ROOF --
IN TERMS OF RESEARCH NEEDS I
THINK IS IS CRITICAL FOR THE WAY
THAT WE AS AS RESEARCHERS THAT
AT LEAST AT UC DAVIS AT OUR
INSTITUTE --
THE WAY THAT WE RECEIVE FUNDS IS --
WE WE HAVE THESE IN TURN --
AND THE THE PRODUCTS THEMSELVES
ARE SERVE LEFT UP TO THE
DISCRETION OF THE RESEARCHERS
BUT BUT I THINK REALLY --
CRITICAL WOULD BE --
YOU KNOW.
APPROACHES FROM --
THE THE LEGISLATURE AND FROM
FROM AGENCIES SUCH AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION YOU
KNOW COMING TO US WITH SPECIFIC
RESEARCH NEEDS THAT COULD THEN
BE.
YOU KNOW TOPICS THAT THAT COULD
BE USED AS AS PROPOSALS --
FOR FOR FUNDING I THINK WOULD BE --
VERY MUCH BENEFICIAL TO SORT OF
COORDINATES --
THE NEEDS AND AND WHAT WE'RE
JUST TO ECHO WHAT DOCTOR DONE
TRANSPORTATION INSTITUTE
CURRENTLY DOES COMMUNICATE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION WITH CALTRANS ON WITH
ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES AND
THAT'S BEEN.
REALLY HELPFUL IN HELPING US
FIGURE OUT WHAT RESEARCH MIGHT
BE USEFUL SO I THINK MORE AND
CONTINUED SUPPORT LIKE THAT
WOULD BE VERY VALUABLE --
AT THE SAME TIME I I THINK IT'S
USEFUL TO LEAVE SOME OF THE
MONEY MORE TO THE DISCRETION OF
THE THE RESEARCHERS WHO MAY HAVE
BRIGHT IDEAS THAT.
I HAVEN'T THOUGHT ABOUT IN THIS
GIVE THEM A CHANCE FOR A TRAINED
DEMONSTRATE THAT.
AND THEN THE FINAL THING IS I
WOULD SAY IN THIS IS IS SORT OF
GETS. TO THE WAY UNIVERSITIES
OPERATE FACULTY ARE OFTEN NOT.
GIVEN THE SORT OF THE FUNDING
AND THIS THE MORAL SUPPORT TO GO
OUT AND SHARE THEIR FINDINGS
WITH THE PUBLIC DOES VERY
INSULAR WORLD OF PROFESSORS
TALKING TO PROFESSORS WHICH I
THINK IS UNHELPFUL --
AND SO TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
STATE.
AS IT FUNDS UNIVERSITY RESEARCH
WANTS TO VERY EXPLICITLY STATE
THAT IT IS AN EXPECTATION THAT
THE AUTHORS WILL SERVE
ENERGETICALLY.
SPEAK AT PUBLIC SERVING EVENTS
WOULD I THINK BE HELPFUL YES YES
WITH THIS AND COMMUNITY MEETINGS
AND AND EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN.
THE I I ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH
THAT -- ANY
NOTION THAT --
THAT NEW WITH THIS MONEY IS IS
BEING USED FOR SORT OF NOW
PUBLIC GOOD AND AND
DISSEMINATING THE RESEARCH AND
INTO THE PUBLIC I THINK WOULD BE.
VERY VERY CRITICAL.
YOU KNOW WHEN IT WHEN I CAME
HERE THERE WAS NO REASON.
SO WHEN WE PUT SB ONE TOGETHER
WE SAID WELL.
LET'S FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO SOME
RESEARCH BECAUSE WE FOUND OUT
THE AND YOU MIGHT KNOW THE
STATE'S --
SEVERAL OTHER STATES HAVE MORE
VIGOROUS ACADEMIC RESEARCH
FUNDED BY THE STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES I THINK.
TAXES IS THE FAMOUS ONE THEY
HAVE.
THE TEXAS TRANSPORTATION
INSTITUTE RYDEN.
OHIO AND MICHIGAN SOME OF THE
STATE SO BIG.
I DON'T KNOW BUT WE'RE WE WERE
WE HAD WE HAD CREATED THESE
INSTITUTES.
BASICALLY BECAUSE THE CONGRESS
RIDE WITH A CONGRESSMAN MINETA.
IS THE IN IN THE BILL HE WROTE
CREATED THESE.
NATIONAL ACADEMIC TRANSPORTATION
INSTITUTE'S ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
AND I THINK CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
WHAT SEVEN OF THEM.
NUMBER KEEPS SAYING I DON'T KNOW
THERE'S A NUMBER.
A YEAR TO YEAR TWO OF MY NO
DAVIS AND THE NET INSTITUTES AS
A STATE.
WITHIN THEIR SERVICE I THINK --
OF SEVERAL.
SEE ISSUE AND STE AND SEVERAL UC
BERKELEY.
UCLA AND SO FORTH RIVERSIDE I
BELIEVE --
IRVINE I BELIEVE YOU SEE A RUN.
FOR A SO SO --
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME
DISCUSSION OF LIKE HOW WE CAN
SUPPORT YOUR INSTITUTES ON
ALLOCATION THAT'S GIVEN AND THEN.
AND THEN I AGREE WITH YOU THE
CONNECTION IS VERY VITAL FOR US
IS POLICYMAKERS --
TO LOOK AT THE RESEARCH AND HAVE
IT PRESENTED.
BOTH BOOKED AT THE STATE LEVEL
BUT ALSO AT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ALL THOSE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PEOPLE.
COMING UP TO CITY COUNCILS THE
PUBLIC WORKS DIRECTORS THE
REGIONAL.
COVER AND GOVERNMENT AGENCIES --
THOUGH CALTRANS --
STAFF MEETINGS PRESENTING
RESEARCH TO THE STAFF AT
CALTRANS THE WITH THE PEOPLE
THAT DO.
SERVER THE RESEARCH SO THEY CAN.
HELP THEM DO THEIR JOBS BETTER I
THINK ALL THAT. FOR THE FOR THE
BUSINESS OF BUILDING OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM I THINK
IT'S VITAL THAT WE HAVE THAT
RESEARCH.
SO I ALL OF THE WORKING WITH YOU
ON HOW TO STRENGTHEN THAT.
AND GET IDEAS FROM ANYBODY THAT
WOULD LIKE TO COMMUNICATE WITH
US -- YOUR
ROTOR USER CHARGE US THE
QUESTION ON WOULD YOU WOULD YOU
CHANGE THE ROAD USER CHARGE
RIGHT AWAY OR HOW WOULD YOU GO
ABOUT DOING.
WELL.
IN IN ABOUT THE WELL I BELIEVE
CLEARLY STATE THAT --
THE WAY WE TO JUST PUT A HUNDRED
DOLLAR REGISTRATION FEE.
THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT.
YEAH WELL YOU KNOW IT
UNDERSTANDABLY SO I I MEAN
CALIFORNIA'S NOW THE TWENTIETH
STATE THE HAS IMPLEMENTED A
REGISTRATION FEE FOR ELECTRIC
VEHICLES.
IT IS EASY TO IMPLEMENT AND
CHEAP TO ADMINISTER RIGHT --
AND FORWARD --
I I I I WILL SAY FOR THE FOR THE
ROOT USER CHARGE I THINK YOU
KNOW WE WE WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
CALTRANS
IS WORKING WITH THE WITH THE
ROAD USER CHARGE AND AND I
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS GOING TO
BE -- A
PILOT HAPPENING IN THE NEAR
FUTURE THAT WILL THERE'S GONNA
BE SEVERAL PILES BUT ONE OF THE
PILOTS IS TO LOOK SPECIFICALLY
AT THIS IMPLEMENTATION FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLES --
AND SO YEAH I THINK THAT'LL BE A
PROMISE LIST KEEP WORKING ON
THAT THAT'LL BE THE WAY AND I
KNOW.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT DOING ACADEMIC
RESEARCH AT THE MINUTE IS --
TO TERMS OF REVENUES CAN YOU
KIND OF GO OVER WHAT OTHER KINDS
OF THINGS YOU'RE DOING I'M SHORT
SO WE'RE GOING TO BE CONTINUING
OUR NATIONAL ANNUAL SURVEY WE'RE
GOING TO BE STARTING UP WELL.
WE'RE DOING A CALIFORNIA FOCUSED
TRANSPORTATION SURVEY TO FIND
OUT WHAT THE GENERAL PUBLIC
THINKS ABOUT VARIETY OF TOPICS
AN ESSENTIALLY CAN DO THIS IS AN
ANNUAL TREND AS WELL.
ON ONE THING BECAUSE I'VE ALSO
WORKED OVER THE YEARS THINKING
ABOUT MILEAGE FEES IS I KNOW
THAT MY ONE CONCERN IS THEY'RE
NOT SUPER POPULAR AND SO JUST
HAVING.
EVEY OWNERS PAY THEM ALMOST CAN
SEEM LIKE A PENALTY ON PEOPLE
WHO OWN ELECTRIC VEHICLES WHICH
IS OF COURSE CONTRARY TO THE
STATE'S GOALS OF ENCOURAGING
MORE PEOPLE --
AND SO THAT WILL JUST BE
SOMETHING ALONG WITH THE MILEAGE
FEED.
IT OCCURS TO ME THAT WE HAVE YOU
EVER MORE ESSENTIALLY CORPORATE
FLEETS OF VEHICLES AND DIFFERENT.
GUISES WHETHER THAT'S UPS TRUCKS
OR LIFT DRIVERS.
AND COLLECTING SAY A MILEAGE FEE
FROM ALL THESE VEHICLES WHICH
ARE ALREADY BEING TRACKED
THEY'RE ALL ARE READY YOU KNOW
GPS IS TELLING US WHERE THEY GO
AND WHEN.
AND IT COULD POTENTIALLY BE A
MATTER OF THE STATE COLLECTING
THOSE REVENUES YOU KNOW FROM A
HANDFUL OF LARGE COMPANIES NOT
HAVING TO DEAL WITH.
A BILL TO EVERY CALIFORNIAN.
COULD BE A VERY ADMINISTRATIVE
FULLY.
EASY WAY TO IMPLEMENT MILEAGE
FEES TO SORT OF START WITH THAT
PORTION OF THE FLEET.
AND ALSO I THINK FROM THE
PUBLIC'S PERSPECTIVE I MEAN I
PAY MY MY LISTS.
THE WHATEVER IT IS I DON'T THINK
ABOUT WHAT PERCENTAGES TAXES AND
WHAT PERCENTAGE IS GOING TO THE
DRIVER AND ALL OF THAT --
AND SO I THINK IT'S JUST A WAY
THAT.
YOU KNOW JUST GETS WORKED INTO
THE PRICE FOR THE NEWMAN MY UPS
PACKAGE COMES ARE I TAKE MY
LISTER OVERRIDE.
SO IT'S NOT I THINK MAYBE AS
WORRY.
TAX IS JUST PART OF WHAT I PAY I
PAY TWENTY DOLLARS A SIXTY
DOLLARS OR WHATEVER IF. TO FILL
UP MY TANK AND I DON'T WORRY
ABOUT BUDGETING FOR THE GAS TAX
OR ANYTHING IT'S JUST.
IT'S INVISIBLE MORE LAST SO
AGAIN I THINK THERE'S SOME.
SORT OF POLITICAL AND AND PUBLIC
ACCEPTABILITY REASONS WHY THESE
MIGHT BE THESE FLEET VEHICLES
MIGHT BE A GOOD WAY TO TO BEGIN
IMPLEMENTING A MILEAGE.
NOW YOU YOU --
JUST SO LAST QUESTION FOR A
JOURNALIST PUBLIC TO TESTIFY --
YOU YOU --
HAD A LIKE A A PRIMER ON WHAT
KIND OF FACTORS.
YOU SHOULD CONSIDER WHEN YOU'RE
CONSIDERING FUNDING
TRANSPORTATION.
YOU KNOW LIKE MAINTENANCE
PROJECT IN YOU HAD IF YOU HAD
LIKE A PRETTY GOOD.
PRIMER.
I MEMBER LIKE I'M I'M THINKING
LIKE. THREE FOUR YEARS AGO YOU
PERCENT OF THIS TO ME YOU HAVE A
GOT A COMMUNITY MEETING WE HAD
ON YOU WE HAD THE FIRST HEARINGS.
IN THE SENATE BEFORE WE START
DEVELOPING I THINK THAT FRAME
WE'RE JUST LOOKING AHEAD.
YOU HEARD THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PEOPLE SAYING THEY THEY FUNDED
PART OF THEIR THIS DEFICIT BUT
NOT ALL OF IT SO THEY'RE NOW
KIND OF WONDERING.
HOW DO WE CLOSE THAT GAP AND
HEARD LIKE THE GENERAL FUND WE
HEARD ALL THESE DIFFERENT --
I THINK IT I THINK WOULD BE
HELPFUL IF YOU HAD.
THAT PRIMER APPLY TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO HELP THEM.
CONSIDER WAYS OF FUNDING.
OF THE MAINTENANCE BACKLOG THAT
THEY STILL HAVE BECAUSE THEY
OBVIOUSLY STILL.
AND WE'RE GOING TO GET A
REPORTER THINK FROM THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES AND SEE SACK OF
BROUGHT THE THE MAINTENANCE
BACKLOG HOW TO THE HELL WHAT
WOULD BE THE RIGHT WAY TO DEAL
WITH THAT AND HOWEVER THE
APPROACH THAT ISSUE.
I THINK --
PRIMER LIKE YOU GAVE ME FOUR
YEARS AGO.
ON FIGURING OUT WHAT KIND OF
APPROACHES WE SHOULD TAKE ON THE
STATE WIDE SP ONE YOU REALLY
HELPED I THINK AT THAT TIME.
US IN DESIGNING SP ONE I JUST
SAY THAT I MEAN YOUR YOUR WORK
YOUR RESEARCH HELPED US.
DESIGN SB ONE IN A AND I
APPRECIATE YOU DOING THAT.
THAT REALLY HELPED THE STATE
CALIFORNIA.
SO -- I
DON'T KNOW IT WOULD BE DIFFICULT
AND I LET ME --
LOOK INTO THAT IT'S AN EXCELLENT
IDEA TO BE HONEST I NEVER
THOUGHT OF TRANSLATING ARE KIND
OF STATE.
LEVEL GUIDE TO THE LOCAL LEVEL
BUT I THINK IT WOULD ACTUALLY BE
PRETTY --
STRAIGHTFORWARD IN SOME WAYS TO
DO AND I WOULD LOVE TO DO IT SO
OKAY WE'LL GET BACK TO YOU ON
THAT.
OKAY --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
HERE -- WHAT
ONE FOR ANYBODY WITH ANYBODY
LIKE TO SAY ANY WORDS TO US AT
THIS TIME THE PUBLIC?
BY PUBLIC COMMENT.
YES COME FROM FORD PLEASE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
YEAH GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M VALERIE NARRA
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE.
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU FOR
PUTTING TOGETHER THIS PANEL.
I THINK IT'S REALLY GOOD THAT
YOU BROUGHT US TOGETHER TO TALK
ABOUT THE FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER SUPPORTS
REASONABLE AND NECESSARY FUNDING
TO ENSURE LONG TERM STABILITY.
OF THE CALIFORNIA'S ROADS
BRIDGES AND INFRASTRUCTURES ALL
OF WHICH IS NECESSARY TO MOVE
CALIFORNIA MADE GOODS.
AND AN INSURANCE VIBRANT ECONOMY
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONTINUE
TO MAINTAIN AND ENCOURAGE POLICY
FOR ADEQUATE OVERSIGHT.
AND USE OF TRANSPORTATION
DOLLARS.
AN IMPLEMENT MEASURABLE
BENCHMARKS AND PERFORMANCE MAKES
OUTCOMES FOR THE YOU CITIES
DOLLARS SECOND THANK YOU FOR
CONVENING A PANEL THANK YOU KNOW
WE ARE TOTALLY AGREE WITH THE
CHAMBER ON THAT ISSUE THANKS
GREAT.
OF ANYBODY ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK OKAY WELL THANK YOU --
THANK EVERYBODY FOR COMING --
WILL DURING THIS COMMITTEE